Ladies, gentlemen, and non-biney-finey, welcome to
WrestleTuber 2024, day two, day one.
One was an intense day of London bridges, colorful
characters, and a bit of stuff.
But what surprises await us today?
Stay tuned!
And now, presenting your overlord, your caster, the one, the
only, donkey!
Oh my god, wow.
I did not expect that intro Oh my god Just need you guys to
know He was very nervous before we started He was like I
don't know what to say guys Oh wow that was amazing Give it
up for our announcer there Woo Anyway welcome to Day 2 of
WrestleTuber what we'll be doing for day two is the
remaining brackets and then the finals to find out who will
be the champion um of wrestle tuber 2024 uh very exciting
day today we actually have it's it's a little less scuffed
they're still gonna be scuffed because i am a one mad obs
person but but but we did improve that we did improve the
tech and behind the scenes for all of you guys so I hope you
guys look I even have my own cut like we even had time to
afford a custom headset as well instead of the default
headset but we actually have a set schedule for the casters
as well as what the matches are so I'll give you guys the
rundown of the brackets and who's to be casting who?
Mint and I will be casting the finals, the last couple of
final matches.
So at the first set of rotations, we actually have two
special guests that will be doing, that will be casting the
show matches for us.
We have someone that has been in the actual WWE casting the
show match with BuffBuff, Bluzy, Maryletter, and Shy Lily.
And so our special guest is actually Jibo.
If you guys don't know who Jibo is, he was in the actual WWE
Mason Mace.
If you guys don't remember Mason.
He was actually in WWE and he will be doing the casting with
Taka for the show match.
I'm sorry, it's not John Cena.
Sorry, Mason D Madden.
It is not, guys, it is not John Cena.
I mean, technically he could be there.
He could just be in the background.
We don't really know.
You can't really see him.
Anyway, so for the brackets, after the show match, match.
This will be our bracket for the day.
It's a little bit more professional now.
So the very first match after the brackets, sorry, after the
show match will be Fuyo versus Snuffy.
Then after that, whoever wins that match will be against
Nana.
And then whoever wins that match will be against Emma.
And then after that, we have bracket two.
This bracket will be casted by and Phillion.
So right after the show matches with our guest casters, Taka
and Jibo, we will have Snuffy and Phillion casting these
matches in bracket two.
Sorry, this is the original.
I just say there will be a little bit of scuff.
And they will also be casting Luto versus Sayu as well.
After that, we will rotate our casters with Kai and Octavio.
Unfortunately, Gerard has to, Gerard has to, uh, uh, is sick
right now, so he will be substituted by Kai, uh, and from
there, uh, they will be casting the winner of the Luto vs.
Side match against Anon, and then after that, they will be
casting for the, two of the final matches, um, for the final
matches, for the final bracket, we, Mint and I will be
spinning a wheel.
to to dictate who will be facing who in the final bracket
and from then on and then we find the champion yay it's
gonna be a very exciting day i hope you guys will enjoy uh
day two i am going it's gonna be very fun i'm so excited and
i'm really happy with um how like talented everybody was,
how incredible everyone was from day one, and everybody's
hard efforts, and all the participants so far in
WrestleTuber.
I hope you guys will enjoy day two, everybody.
I really do hope you guys will enjoy day two.
Anyway, from there on, remember, do you guys remember what
the belt looks like?
Because whoever's going to win this show match will be
bringing this belt home tonight.
Well, not tonight.
They still have to ship it.
PNG tonight all right well I guess that's it for me in the
main casting chair so let's go over to our guest casters in
the interview section bye guys
what a day for wrestling let me tell you it's great to be
here back to V-Tubing after 10 months alongside you Yibo
Dhaka it is pandemonium in the wrestle drone are you feeling
tonight you had to come out of uh hiatus i had to come out
of retirement this is a big fight field oh it's at without a
shout out without night one was explosive so that means
night two will be implosive it expands and now it retracts
and as it retracts more things will be colliding in the
center of that squared circle ladies and gentlemen i i'm
going to explore it all over the place taka we are both
guest casting here tonight i am yellow snow takahada and i
am by Dick Inkey Yebo.
Yes, you can call me Dick Inkey.
That is my commentary name.
I'm the only person here to have Vince McMahon yapping in my
ear during commentary during a horrible Hell in a Cell
match.
Tonight, I've got Doki in my ear.
So if I say anything bad, it's her fault.
There we go.
You confirmed her right here.
She is the master of this domain.
Her domain has expanded to encapsulate professional
wrestling as well.
And we're up for a heck of a first bout here because I
brought you up.
we're having a mixed tag action and i believe we have an
interview set to be taking away please take us away juna
hello thank oh thank you so much hello um right now we have
we have oh uh i'm sorry oh it's so cute we have mary lucy
shy lily and the buff pup here right now they are hello you
scared me we were talking and we like got thrown in here and
i got scared i was like Keep your eye.
Yes, Orton, sit aside.
Lay your praises upon me, for I have arrived.
Whoa.
Amazing.
We are, our show match will be consisting of two tag teams,
consisting of Mary and Buffpup and Lucy and Shy Lily.
So for the two dog pros, how are you feeling about this
match so far?
Well, I'm, when it comes to double D's, that's what we are,
we're the double D crew.
Okay, I feel very confident just because dogs get things
done so yeah yeah dogs back we're just gone well that's true
i'm certain we're going to win because i've got buff pop so
i mean that's true and also like i like bones so like if i
make charlie and lucy a skeleton then i can just take them
so oh i see him yeah i didn't think about that well what did
the two cute girls have to say in response i want buff to
sit on my face all right done easy i got a bone that you can
chew There's not much work.
There's a bunch of banter between both tag teams.
The tension is both palpable and sexual, Yibo.
I'm palpitating all over the place right now, Taka.
That's what wrestling is about, just like body contact with
way too much skin.
Yeah, honestly, like if I win or lose, like I think I'm
winning regardless, so, you know.
I'm winning either way.
I'm happy to hear that there's great sportsmanship and
skinship here with all of the contestants in the show match.
Well, other than being choked and being sat on, I hope you
guys do well in the ring and good luck.
Thank you so much.
Yes, of course.
Goodbye.
Please fight me.
See you.
Bye.
Now I gotta say, one tag team is absolutely gorgeous.
Well, they're both gorgeous, to be honest, but one team does
appear to have that dog in them.
Dog is very important when it comes to a professional
wrestling match, Taka.
Because they can run around on all fours like a hound.
But so can cats.
That's true.
But not like hounds, but like cats.
Speaking of cats and dogs, that's what this scrap is going
to be all about.
Let me tell you.
It's like a feral free-for-all.
A fere-for-all.
A fere-for-all, correct.
Absolutely.
Now, I got to get, let's take it away to a ring announcer.
sir in this corner you can hear them barking from two
corners of the planet you have the buff bro buff pop and
attention is palpable I do not know what they're about to
say well what's happening right now is the is the big dog is
making their entrance singles because they are taking their
sweet time I mean, when you look at this buff, you look this
talented, you look this amazing, you'd take your time to
basking in this adulation from this wonderful capacity crown
of over 13,000 people in the Ressler Trooper Dome.
What?
What state are we in right now?
A state of denial, Yibo.
Yes, yes, that's the correct answer.
Because no one can deny.
audience how buff this pup is where where does that tail go
bring it out sir this guy and in this corner
it's finally making his debut the dogman himself the
gentleman meriwether
see that is a classy outfit there that that's it looks
expensive It looks, uh, it looks...
Svelvety.
I get appreciate Maryweather getting a custom model just for
this occasion with their symbol on the back.
Money, money, money, money, money, money, money, money
Money, money, money, money.
Money, money, money, money!
Usually people smoke in that jacket, but he may end up
smoking the competition in it.
Yeah, let's see if he can make it rain on his competition
tonight.
Mm-hmm.
opponents coming in from the other side of the ring it's not
just Lucy juicy it's Lucy pyre now hold on now Taka did she
just wake up I clearly she was napping in the back they got
themselves a coffee they still have brought the blanket
because they're not fully awake you know that thing when you
wake up in the morning you're like i'm gonna go get my
coffee and like you know i i i appreciate the dedication to
taking some time to get some sleep because the one thing you
don't want to do is sleep on the competition and that it
might be what i just wonder if i just wonder if she's fully
prepared for what's going on today it looks like she's still
napping well hopefully she starts with rest holds to start
the match and maybe they'll wake up oh yeah that's a little
insider baseball for you guys in the chat that's for the
that's for all the smarts in the audience all the smart
marks and her teammate coming in she's not just a wailing
gotcha games
it's shy lily all right from the bedroom to the pool house
Maybe they were sleeping in the same place.
Maybe they were sleeping in the pool house.
Either way, Shire Lily, wamp, wamp indeed, ladies and
gentlemen.
I have seen how she has destroyed a pineapple.
This person can destroy the competition.
The crowd is wamping.
What did she destroy the pineapple with?
You know what?
It's best left unsaid.
Interesting, interesting.
And the crowd is wamping.
Don't you see the wampage happening in the audience?
as you can hear them Wompa Media.
Wompa Media is running wild.
Wompa!
Wom!
Look at the eyes.
The eyes tell a story.
The eyes don't lie and the eyes spell disaster tonight at
Sacrifice.
The apex mammal of our species.
And their opponents are in for a whale of a time.
That's good tucker thank you thank you you should get a
raise you know what you know what
maybe maybe if you're good speaking of good this match is
brought to you by gamer subs everybody thank you for all of
you to attending this wonderful event and let's get this
thing started with some tag team action let's go it's a
tornado tag look at the size of buff pup I'm a bit of a tag
team aficionado myself.
I'm undefeated on the Independence champion in multiple
countries.
So if you have any questions for how to win a tornado tag
team match, feel free to ask me.
Okay.
So as a...
Now, if you're the biggest person in the tag match, like
Buff Pupp is, how do you avoid getting targeted by the
wierly, small, tiny ones?
Just like that.
You do a Thespress and you beat the pulp out of the face,
Taka.
If you stay off the ground, can't put you on the ground.
And look at that!
Look at that!
She just sat on her!
That cake-based offense.
Now, Mary just grabbed a sledgehammer from underneath the
ring.
Now, this is an extreme rules tornado tag match, and this is
essentially a complete anarchy already.
Shia Lily's got a steel chair!
She got steel chair!
Everything goes!
Narrowly avoiding the chair.
Buff-puff avoiding the damage, locking up with Shia Lily yet
again, and Shia Lily decides to walk the dog to the road.
Oops.
Oh, if you put the dog on the leash, they're not going to
like that very much, Taka.
Oh, and just kneeling.
Lucy.
Oh, and that's exactly what you need to do against a larger
opponent, Taka.
You've got to chop the tree down, break down the legs, and
make sure they have nothing to walk on.
Cork screwing them.
Oh, kicking apart all the limbs.
Oh, a pin attempt is being made.
That's not just a pin.
That's a sexy pin.
Sidewalk slam, maybe?
Oh.
I believe they call that deep pin attrition.
It rhymes with attrition.
Makes me want to get back in the ring, Taka.
It does.
I mean, you've got to be feeling enamored by these
superstars in the ring.
Buff Pup laying in an absolute clinic.
Oh, now the numbers game.
How would you handle someone with the size and buffness of
Buff Pup?
Well, honestly, Taka, I've never been in the ring with
somebody bigger than me.
I'm approximately nine feet tall and 800 pounds, but there
was somebody who was...
Oh my God!
What was the sledgehammer throw?
They threw a sledgehammer at Lucy Pyer's head!
Absolutely no regard for human society and well-being.
They say dog is man's best friend, but they can also be your
worst enemy if you cross him.
Oh, look at that's Chekhov's table right there.
Somebody's got to go through it by the end of the match.
Otherwise, everybody's going to be disappointed.
One armed Press!
That's the size advantage there, Taka.
Oh, and a knuckle shuffle.
That wasn't all five.
That was just four knuckles.
We see Mary going again for another item.
Oh, I got a trash can!
About to take out the trash!
Somebody says, you know, who is trash?
Mary's saying that Lucy Pire belongs to the trash.
Oh, what a beautiful!
move by bus pop there it looks to me like the dogs are in
control the dog and now going for a sneaky pin here like
hold on kick out at one but we got us tables we have a table
at play the crowd is going wild they're saying tables tables
tables oh nice this is hard to even call this is now it
looks like the team of Shia Lily and Lucy have managed to
start matching up with the dogs a little bit more now trying
to keep pace lucy grabbing the garbage can she was placed in
oh i thought we were going to see a double team on the
outside perhaps being sandwiched between the trash can and
two dogs
shyly throwing but oh and a rolling damage there to buff up
who just slammed into the great as mary is picking apart
lucy pyre on the other side the dogs are firmly in control
here tonight, Taka.
The dogs are barking, and that's not just from the audience,
folks.
But dogs can get overly worked out.
They can tire themselves out before even realizing it, and
that's the challenge.
Can their singular... Oh, it just threw that in the back of
Shantily Lee's head!
Unbelievable!
Now, Taka, that's actually a great point.
Could the dogs have started off really hot and maybe tucker
themselves out before the match is over?
a game of attrition it really depends are they in the small
dog park or the big dog park oh I see a couple of big dogs
and a couple of people in the audience are chanting for the
big dogs but I guess we'll find out who when they win
tonight Lucy being double-teamed by Mary a buck buck buck
buck striking a pose taunting arrogance will we'll have to
see if that comes back to bite them but Lucy grabbing an
item from under his mind was about to grabs him from under
the ring, but no, Bump Pup's got a, oh, beautiful.
Oh, turning neckbreaker into even more offense.
Chai Lilly taunting the opponents to get into the ring.
Into the hammerlock.
What is this?
What is Chai Lilly going for here?
And that's a beautiful back body drop.
Lucy's on fire!
Oh!
Will that be enough for Bump Pup?
Oh, break up by Shai Lilly.
This is the danger of a tornado match.
Oh, a big dog punch!
blood blood kick out of two only two that was close taka
what is pop pop doing that's 500 pounds of oh never mind
we're good go fine oh no okay no that's smart he's too big
to go up there just taking out just taking out shy lily oh
my gosh she's got a family one beat down oh and lucy takes a
steel crown of the head from mary Oh, a pop-up drop kick.
Oh, a reverse.
I'm slightly reversing it.
Oh, and a drop kick from Mary.
This is...
This is getting hard to watch, Tommy.
Oh, this is some PWG-style wrestling right now.
Oh, my God.
Buff-Pup with the sledgehammer.
Haunting the opponents.
They've been pretty cocky since the start of this match.
Oh, hitting Mary!
Muffpump just hit Mary in the back of the head.
Couldn't take advantage.
She couldn't take advantage of the miscommunication, and
they are back on the same page.
The dogs are in sync.
Silently thrown away.
Lucy Pire grabbing hold of Mary, throwing Mary back in the
ring.
Pinfalls have to occur inside the ring, to my knowledge.
And Lucy- That's very true.
Oh!
Pulling Muffpump.
What's this?
Oh!
My goodness!
Topi!
Topi sueshida!
Mama Mia!
Buffpup is, what is Buffpup thinking right now?
Oh, into the steps!
Somebody's got to go through that table, Taka.
Bad booking.
Someone has to, we have three tables at play right now, and
oh, oh, back in the, oh, back in the head.
But it's not in the ring, it's not in the ring.
Oh!
Mary had the candlestick knocked out of their hand.
Buff Pup is observing.
This is their chance.
This could be it.
He's woofing up.
And now the teams are switching.
Now they're both targeting.
They're going after Lucy again.
It's that pack-a-dog mentality, Taka.
Never mind.
Mary has decided to switch up and go after her shot.
Oh, miss.
Did they hit?
No, they did hit.
Wow.
It's really not safe to be throwing these weapons around.
Don't throw Kendo sticks.
That's not a...
blood on the outside.
Bup, Bup taking apart Lucy.
And Shia Lily makes Mary pay for it on the outside.
In all my years, I don't think I've ever seen a match this
brutal.
What is Bup, Bup doing on the outside?
On the outside.
That's the hardest part of the ground, Taka.
Back of the, back of the head.
Whoa, oh my God, Mary almost tapped out.
Mary almost tapped out there for a second.
This could be it.
Oh, now she's bleeding, too.
Mary going for a pin.
One, two.
Oh, that's it.
She was so close.
Last second.
Your winners.
Give a good old bark for the dogs.
Meriwether and Boff Paul.
not only did they have those dogs in them those dogs won now
their opponents have their dog in them too man's best friend
man's worst enemy Taka what do you think what what did you
expect going into that match did you expect that outcome I
actually expected Shia Lily to be bigger than buff pup
whales are very big Yeah, yeah, they start off pretty big,
but big dogs stand on top.
That's true.
We're also on land, so.
Wow.
What a show.
I can't believe the double Ds.
They won.
I need to ask, I must ask the two cute girls, how did it
feel having a very buff big dog?
come at you with a sledgehammer.
I would be shitting my pants if I was in your position.
I need to say something.
Why was she, oh my god.
Why was she, where the alpha cut off?
Is that as good for you as it was for me, pop?
Honestly, I was scared.
There was one point where I thought I was gonna get like 18
plus and I was really nervous.
I was like, I was like, I was like, oh my god, I feel so
bad.
I literally was like bashing everyone's head with a
sledgehammer.
I don't know what the heck came over me.
I need a rabies vaccine after.
I even hate Mary.
We have to call 911 again.
911, please.
Well, for the double D team.
Round two?
Nice.
Either, bro.
We'll do round two next weekend.
Okay, okay.
On my place.
Well.
Well, does the double T have any?
I think he needs to be put down.
I need backup.
Please.
I can't drink water.
I need, hello.
Cut the cameras.
I need, I need help.
Don't worry, buddy.
Just, it's the rabies.
It's the rabies.
It's okay.
That dog needs to be neutered.
I'm my dog alone.
He's fine.
He's just excited.
Come on.
Got this, don't worry.
She got it under control to worry about it.
You saw in the match, she had to, like, put him in place as
well in the match.
I did, I hit him in the back of the head with a sword chain.
She had no friends only in the whole match.
I love wrestling!
I love her!
Rory, it's like, just give him a second in the crate.
He'll be all right after.
In the crate, all right, I understand.
He just, he still needs crate training.
He's just a puppy.
He needs to be trained and leashed.
Well, do you, thank you so much for the show match.
Do any of you guys have any words for the upcoming matches,
like any motivational speeches that you could possibly give
them?
I better see some bloodshed.
I better see some double D action out there.
Okay, I want to see, I want to see some flinging, some
flying, some barking even.
Maybe some sweat.
I need sweat and blood and sweat and sweat and I hope it
gets sweaty.
I think we're getting a cream for next week.
meet up well thank you ladies and gentlemen for joining us
for our shore shore mash i can't speak i'm so sorry i'm i'm
okay well it was a pleasure having you guys here and i hope
you i hope all of you guys get baby shot i'm gonna get
through oh god no more we got them we still love this every
they've got too much of that dog in them dick inky i will
say that somebody call animal control because that animal is
out of control.
Absolutely.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for being the guest caster for the show match.
I guess this is behind the scenes Doki here.
We're going to be going back to the main stage everybody.
But let's say a huge thank you to everybody here for the
show matches and the winners of the show match.
The dogs.
I was very surprised they beat the anime girls.
But I guess So, I guess...
Every dog has its day.
Some girls might need some rabies shots later.
Anyway, say thank you to all the people there.
We're going to go back to the main stage to get ready for
the tournament.
Thank you.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, wow.
I forgot to take the belt off.
Hey, like I said, thank you.
the people at the show match um that was fucking extreme it
was a last minute change I know originally it was like a
tornado tag but then I decided to change it to extreme
because I was like whoa they can like throw hammers so I had
to include it again a huge shout out to our guest casters
give me a sec I want to be sure if um Snuffy and Philean are
ready to cast the beginning of the tournament.
So give me a sec as I cue them in.
Guys, one man army here.
If they're not ready, we will have a little change of
casters.
We might have Kai and Octavio to start us off.
So just give me a sec as I check it out here.
waiting uh for those who are waiting um the first match is
not this one that is not the first match the first match was
technically fuio versus snuffy uh but at the moment i am not
sure if snuffy is in the ring at the moment so if we do not
have um if snuffy and snuffy is not here yet we will might
have Octavio and Kai come over to do bracket two I believe
we to do bracket two for Araka and Luto so for now at the
moment I don't believe Snuffy is in the stadium at the
moment so we are going to have a little slight change of the
casters and we are going to have Kai um kai and octavio to
come in to cast for luto and saiyu um so give me a sec
everybody as i uh ping let them know um let oh they should
know they're in this call kai and octavio are you guys ready
to cast the first match kai and octavio pinging kai and
octavio you guys can talk Oh, we can talk.
Yeah, we can talk.
You guys can talk in the headset to let me know.
I'm just sending emojis.
I was like, we are here for sure.
You guys are here.
That is good to know.
I was a little worried when I didn't get any response.
I'm sorry, Aaron.
And no one's here for some reason.
We're in the break room.
Yeah, yeah, we were peeing them from the break room.
I had to be sure they were here and ready to cast before I
rotate them in.
But yes, thank you again to Kai for substituting for Gerard.
Are you guys ready to cast for your first match?
Do you guys remember what your first match is?
Yes.
Who are they?
Who are they before I send you over to the interview table?
Oh, shit.
Who are they?
and saw you know yeah yeah all right sending you over to the
interview stage i hope you guys are already sitting down
guys oh yeah i'm coming in whoa oh sorry i just i have a
gigantic i'm sorry it's all it's all gas in there there's
nothing it's empty hello hello sorry i'm trying to like
everyone and welcome to uh day two uh there's been some
really really exciting matches and I hope you guys are ready
for the fucking shit that's about to go down today how are
you feeling Octavio I'm feeling great and you know we are a
follow-up to the awesome Taka and Jibo earlier with that
they have actual WWE experience we do have actual WWE
experience too yesterday we do oh yeah yeah No, for sure.
Yesterday.
Yeah.
And then, and then I lost.
And then that, that counts though, right?
That counts.
Yeah.
For sure.
I won.
Then I lost.
So we're both losers here.
We're like, we're the perfect people.
Yeah, no, it's great.
You know, it'll break like a good perspective, I think.
All right.
The perspective of those who, who will never make it in the
WWE ever.
Okay.
Just sound sad when you put it like, just sound sad.
All right.
all right but hello everybody yeah where are our wrestlers
are they here we are currently waiting for them to come from
the back whoa oh they're coming they sure are coming oh my
god are waiting for them to become smaller i'm sorry i guess
red people today just have really big heads i don't know
it's just how it is what's up with that just how it is i i
don't excuse me hey what don't make me jump over this table
i will fight you right now okay short bitch professional
anyways damn who's fighting here i'm not i'm not quite sure
it should be me in the ring it should be me but it's okay
i'll be professional it's fine it's fine we'll lock in we'll
lock in well we i i'm waiting for a response i'm i wait true
i think luto might still be in the break room maybe having
some cheese and crackers who knows but uh honestly though
honestly while we wait i just want to say um i am very
excited to be substituted in um i saw that we were missing a
red reptile and i was like oh wait i'm also a red reptile
this will work uh so yeah the other reptile extinct already
so that's fine it's over it's the age of the dragon now
way better you think so yeah definitely you know what here's
the thing yesterday i was beaten by a dragon i mean i beat a
dragon oh really and now i'm casting with a dragon so i
think that's character development for me yeah true true
true um although i think you're you're crazy because i don't
think you'd be a dragon but anyway that's that's crazy
that's that's just like my opinion that's that's the way i
want to see things you can't beat a dragon but you know it's
fine you know if you want like lie like that you know that's
cool you know fair and square fight no i didn't see nothing
no i didn't see nothing well i saw your fight no you didn't
you got beaten within like three minutes you didn't you i
don't think you saw anything and i think you're crazy and i
think you're strange for saying that actually yeah excuse me
you had the biggest trash talk in the beginning too you're
like i'm gonna split this lime into two and squirt it into
your eyes oh my god you did Yeah, second.
Alright, okay, down.
No, I would have rather you not perceive me, alright.
No.
Okay, listen.
I need it to at least, like, okay, I'm a firm believer in,
like, manifestation, all right?
If you want something to happen, you've got to believe it's
going to happen, all right?
So I'm like, you know what?
I'm going to, hell, yeah, I'm going to beat her fucking ass.
Hell, yeah, I'm going to fucking win.
But you know what?
Sometimes it just...
That's a lot of talk.
And that's why we're now here, all right?
And I'll be here.
The loser's bracket casting.
Oh, but trust me, if it was me and June on the ring, I would
have win.
I would have won.
So, yeah.
It was just a bad matchup on my end.
We've already met up and we talked about this, Papu.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
No, again, I'm manifesting.
I would literally be...
Stop calling Pukenya, you fucking pukenya.
I literally be right.
I think we need a show match.
Do you see what I have to put up with?
We are getting some response from Luto Real, not Clickbait.
She's on her way.
She's just grabbing some snacks.
Oh, and there she is!
Sayu, Luto!
Are you here?
So that's what my opponent sounds like?
This is definitely Luto.
Yes.
Damn.
Are you inside Sayu?
I'm excited to be here.
It'll be my debut as a wrestler.
It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be great and Luto, How will you defeat someone
that's, you know, four or three times your size?
With my Australian powers and demon powers.
Demon powers.
Australian demon powers.
Yes, because all demons come from Australia.
This is true.
Oh, my.
Kangaroos are.
Kangaroos are fucking terrified.
They're weird.
Yeah, kangaroos and koalas.
They're like demonic.
Yeah.
scary they shouldn't exist um i'm i'm very excited to see
how this will end up i an australian versus an american the
aas yeah you sure sure sure i don't know i i'm not sure i'm
so sorry of the world you're okay it's my first job i am
gonna win uh you're you're just a little robo boy can't
handle all this kangaroo
yeah tell them all yeah tell them yeah well for real i think
they're ready i'm feeling the energy i'm feeling the tension
it's actually kind of scary what the heck yeah i'm scared
you shake it i'm shaking i'm gonna bring my kangaroo Yeah,
you're gonna bring in a kangaroo.
I'll bring out two kangaroos.
I'll bring my computer to smack the shit out of you with.
I'll bring even more computers.
I'm sorry.
I am not sorry.
That's not your secret laugh.
what is going on damn well i think they're ready to go into
the ring yeah yeah i want to see how this goes there all
right and the american oh jesus i gotta look over the table
again i'm sorry i'm too short i'm too short i'm sorry okay
there we go they got they got the steps tool thank you thank
you all right who who do you think is gonna win i'm actually
that's scary that's actually there yeah terrifying was that
honestly my my money was on saiyu but after hearing that
kangaroo stuff i don't know i'm on i'm scared true and
honestly saiyu just looks like a guy yeah bro's just a dude
like it's like a one little guy against a demon from
australia i'm sorry true just look at that hair that
mustache those horns here we go in this corner we have the
handsomest tech support around totally not biased it's not
biased let's fucking go yeah he's announcing himself wow
he's strutting he's walking got that robot low if you think
about it All right, come on.
Hey, shush!
Yeah, it says he tight.
I do love how he's staying on brand.
Right foot forward as well.
Look at this.
Oh.
Oh, he's supposed to be integrating.
It's okay.
Oh, there he goes.
Into the ring.
He rolls in.
All right.
It's funny because he's just tech support.
And he's doing this.
Honestly, I get...
I get surprised at how well you could customize these.
Holy fuck.
And now, coming to the stage after grabbing.
Oh, freaking.
The suspense!
It's Ludo!
Hey, Yasqueen.
Look at that slave.
Yeah!
Let's fucking go!
I didn't expect this very bright outfit, bright pink, blue
and yellow.
Bright is the way to go though, okay?
It makes you look flashy, alright?
You get extra style points.
I love the holographic horn too.
It's a vibe, it's a vibe.
Like, it's just, it's her world and we're just living in it,
really.
Her weird Australian middle world.
Actually, wait, I can't remember.
You got that headphone thing?
You know how the skull gets compressed because of you
wearing headphones he has to look at them oh no don't do him
like that don't do him like that damn a little shimmy all
right all right i see you i see you luto knows how to work
the crowd yeah look at that oh my god wait i just realized
that's a diaper that's a diaper i guess demons need diaper
True.
Bro, I can hear myself.
There we go.
Sayu with a Goku hair.
If Luto's smart, she'd take off the diaper and just yeet it
at him as an intimidation tactic.
Immediately with a...
Oh my god!
Don't tell me this big demon is a high flyer.
He's starting with the freaking aerial moves.
Holy crap!
Already pinned?
Oh, you broke your back.
No.
Oh, focus on the arm.
Yeah, clip those wings.
Those demon wings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, she's in pain.
Oh, oh, she's gonna come back.
Reversal.
Miss the elbow.
Oh, and he brings her top one down.
Sayu targeting the legs here.
Oh!
Oh, that's got a heart.
You know kangaroos are, have really strong punches.
I'm not sure if they're, they're so scary.
Woo!
Ow!
Nice!
Look at that leap.
He's crazy!
This big demon is a high flyer.
Right?
This fucking maneuvering!
That's terrifying!
Ooh, suplex by Sayu.
Oh, they're going back in the ring.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Right.
Sia being polite waited for Luto.
Very nice of him.
To the turnbuckle.
What's going on?
Oh, is she gonna jump on him?
Another aerial!
Oh my god!
No!
Oh, come on!
500 pounds!
Jesus, his ribs are broken!
On top of the tech support!
I think the diaper added more pounds to it too.
Dude, I think so!
Oh god!
Oh geez!
oh oh my god that swing around pretty cool dude they're
maneuvering so good holy crap come on saiyu you got to win
for all tech support guys everywhere you gotta do it from
the back yeah clip those wings yeah that's his that's his
favorite move get around get around flip them over and a pin
from Oh, nah, not even a one count.
No, no, no, no, no.
Come on, you got to step it up.
I'm not feeling impressed yet.
Thanks a lot.
I feel like both of their endurances are really, really
high.
Oh, me to the face.
Freaking jumping around they're doing.
Oh, she keeps missing like that.
Dude, those free aerial kicks just take me out.
every time it's so brutal all right do they get are you
gonna jump another area oh oh but oh here we go oh she gets
oh she gets fucking knocked down it's funny i can't i can't
help but one submission okay true true you kind of you kind
of have to wonder what the heck is in that diaper.
That's true.
It's very, very bloated.
I want to find out if I'm being honest with you.
I don't want to know.
What's scary is that the tail also pops out of the diaper.
So that's already like a hole in there.
So who knows?
Maybe there's a signature move with that diaper.
Oh, no, but they got out.
They're fighting outside.
You got to get in the ring.
Oh, man, Sayu's just getting carried away.
What's the count for?
Damn, Sayu taunting.
Doesn't care about the count.
Right to the hamstrings.
Oh, there we go.
All right, back in there.
There they go.
Luto thinking about her life choices.
Taking her time.
She's taking her time.
She don't need a rush.
Does she want to move from Australia to America after this?
Who knows?
Oh my god.
Poor Luto.
She's just getting beat the fuck up.
Oh my god.
Being dragged on the floor.
Oh, finish her.
Oh.
No, it's it's it's Sayu's favorite move.
Oh, and the the the clip in the wing.
again oh my god yeah you know if you really kind of think
about it it almost looks like saiyu's kind of wearing a
diaper too a little bit just just a little bit for the back
there that's that's a new meta it's a new meta for wrestling
yeah you know it works for intimidation yeah honestly though
if i saw luto the ring i'd ship my pants too so you know
what valid so valid oh oh they're holding hands oh they're
holding hands oh this is oh they throw them out it was
another aerial again oh no that's scary that's scary you're
so far away oh whoa from the
sat on saiyu's face with that dirty diapar oh not quite not
quite almost Oh, rolled out of the ring.
Sayu needed to escape.
Not the miss.
This is actually pretty...
Oh, what's he doing?
He's gonna do it.
He really likes the hands.
Subplex!
Oh, is this gonna be a triple subplex?
How is he doing that?
That demon is a thousand pounds!
And he's just tech support!
Oh man!
Oh man.
Trying to remove, trying to decapitate the demon there.
Oh!
I like how they have the same color scheme.
They can be on one team.
They got like that hot pink going on.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, literally 20.
Oh, oh, is Sayu gonna be counted out?
No, come on, you gotta get out.
Nine!
Sayu!
Not like this!
Lutha wins!
Holy shit!
Lutha won that.
Damn.
By knocking Sayu out of the ring.
After she went to get some snacks,
It's Luto!
Woo!
Holy crap, dude!
I thought I was going to win.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no, that chest is crazy.
That's really big.
That's what the diaper does.
That's the power of the diaper.
Holy shit!
Yeah, it embeds the chest.
And makes everything like really, really strong.
Damn.
Wow.
Luto with a win.
miss luto i i'm gonna be honest i didn't think someone i i
guess you just really look really small in front of me i
don't know you looked super big apparently you were seven
feet tall yeah oh what do you have to say miss luto yeah and
saiyu is standing on a stool
what are you guys talking about i got robbed you got it
wrong would you like to explain how it was a little fast i
think that count was a little fast It went from eight then
nine and then ten just came like a half a second faster.
I'm just saying Also, it's my first day on the job classic
rig card classic hey, you know Yeah, yes, yeah, what yeah,
no, that's it, you know, it was right.
We don't Just take the L and move on that just move on The L
for Luto crazy The only W is for me, the L for you, man!
Luta, I must ask.
I've been curious, and I'm sure the audience is also very
curious.
What was your inspiration for your outfit?
Oh.
I'd like to know that, too, actually.
I wanted to be the most, like, flamboyant one.
I wanted to kill you guys with how gay I am.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, my God.
The power of...
No!
Well, the power of...
I can't believe it.
Sayu has died by gay.
You know what?
A way to go.
Wouldn't have it any other way.
Did you like my diaper?
Did you like it when I sat on your face?
Yeah!
Was it warm, Sayu?
You sat on Sayu's face with the diaper, please?
No, I wasn't a fan of the diaper, but everything else is
fine.
Everything else was fine.
The diaper I wasn't a fan.
Oh, we were fans of it, huh?
Okay.
We really like the diaper.
See, this is why I stick to a desk job.
the match was super close I I you guys went on for a while
and I must say I'm very proud of both of you guys even
though someone may have up their class a little bit because
of a diaper I I think it was a fair fight you really think
about it there was a pin and that's very dangerous on the
diapers so if anything I'm just saying probably just
qualifications could be a thing Sayu, your suit was made out
of metal, so I don't know what you want me to do.
No, it just looks that way.
It just looks that way.
It just looks that way?
What is it?
It's just cloth?
It's just very good cashmere.
I don't know what you want from it.
Oh, yes.
The cope, man.
The cope.
Actually, AI zero, humanity one.
Well, thank you so much.
I am so grateful and honored to have witnessed this match,
and I would like to thank you both for wrestling each other
and thank you congratulations again miss luto oh yeah let's
go weird thank you for wrestling each other thank you for
smashing and dashing and ball smashing thank you thank you
for doing it for juna thank you yes i love watching people
fight i love watching people fight thank you luto thank you
thank you i will sit on you
i'd rather you did it but thank you all right now that was
all for this fight and now we will actually be going back to
the main stage because i believe now we'll be subbing in the
other casters i think we're being kicked out for our diaper
comment i was too far okay i'm sorry yeah listen yeah just i
mean don't get if you want you can give me another chance
right it's fine i promise i promise thank you thank you
Octavio for casting the first game.
We have Snuffy and Philly in the house now.
In the stadium, in the backstage.
Can I'm queuing in?
Can we get Snuffy and Philly on the intercoms for us?
Snuffy and Philly.
Are you guys here?
Hello.
Are you guys ready?
We're ready, boss.
All right, Snuffy.
Do you know who is next in the match?
myself yeah and she's against fuyo yes yes oh miss fuyo whoa
now fuyo is in the building as well how do you feel snuffy
finally how do you feel i get to talk to fuyo the legend
we've been saying a couple words back and forth not gonna
lie to you chat oh yeah why didn't you guys post that on on
Twitter, right?
I should have, I should have, right?
You should tweet that out right now so that the viewer
audience will know what, anyway, for those who don't know.
You better make this pop off, because it's about to age
poorly in 20 minutes.
Yeah, we're talking milk out here.
I need you guys to know, Snuffy and Fuyo were like,
chit-talking each other in the server.
Oh, like they were making like, elaborate videos and
everything to each other, But they never posted it in the
public.
I had no I was like, why can't just tweet that shit out?
What is up with this high effort video shit to each other,
but it just stayed in the discord server I was so confused.
Anyway, next matchup is with Snuffy versus Fuyo and will be
casted by Snuffy and Philly and off to the interview stage
to them
did scrimmable yesterday and now my voice is frick today.
Um, if it cracks then it is what it is.
Also, snuffy did you just use Sadako and Judo stone
yourself?
That's actually an actor I've substituted myself in for.
Okay, you're fighting a leprechaun reject or what's going on
here?
That's, excuse me, that's Fuyo Man?
I can't believe that's Fuyo Man.
Fuyo Man
So that's the way I pull in.
I'm so fucking dead, you guys.
You're dead already, but you haven't even seen it before.
Oh, my God, oh, man, please.
Mercy, mercy.
No, mercy.
Oh, shit.
Come on, man.
I don't know.
It's going to be like this, dude.
I thought, I don't know.
This is, yeah, I want to hear some tender version of Drake
right now.
Like, let's have him make this young public.
All right, and I'm going to, I'm going to be motherfucking
Cheerios, because I've got to eat this leprechaun for
breakfast, dude.
Let's go.
Why did you say lucky Trump?
Last night.
But you were too scared to show up.
Snuff, you're gonna take that?
Yeah.
Let me just, what do these cards say?
Just call me Daft Punk because tonight I'm gonna get lucky.
I'm gonna get lucky.
I'm gonna fold your liquor full of my laundry.
Okay.
I'm over witnessing Twitter in real life right now.
I just want to see them fight.
I just tweeted an aggressive video towards Fuyo Cloverman.
Oh, and you're sub-tweeting right now?
He told me that's what I'm going on.
I can't come up with anything clever, so I'm resorting to
posting on social media.
That's classic.
Fuyo man will destroy.
oh god all right well loser has to delete their twitter can
we agree oh no yeah we'll put all the cards on this one
that's simply the winner well i the tension and i i feel one
is very very ready and the other is a little intimidated
slightly ever so slightly i think but i am excited to see
how but it's finally happening and I'm sure everyone else is
super excited.
Wow, wow, wow.
Are you ready to fight?
It's my grand legacy.
I'm about to win four games in a row in Fulio.
You're going to be the first step on the way to victory.
It's your pain in the vent.
I would like to see you in Chihuahua.
Dang.
Snuck it.
How are you going to commentate yourself?
Don't worry.
It's a hired actor.
This is all a hired actor performance.
list of things that i'm extra skilled at wait it's nothing
we saw seats yesterday i was on the other side how sick is
that my voice is dying one sec oh we bought more than one
seat this time i like sharing our seat yep all right let's
have him get into this junk stuffy what is your what is your
face reveal what is this trash man i go out and i i start
throwing garbage all over the way yeah You look like you
need a gastric bypass.
I don't know if this is going to work out, Snuffy.
This is Danny Stovito.
This is my hired actor.
He's too paid to win the game for me.
Danny Stovito.
In this corner, we have the little green thing becoming the
big green thing.
It's not Fuyo Cloverfield.
It's Fuyo Mervito.
Why is there another diaper?
I can't deal with this man.
Well, Philly in wrestling does get dirties.
He's also about to have the accidents on the ring.
Are those programmer socks?
What is going on, ladies and gentlemen?
Remember, fuck?
Yeah, you see that, John?
No, those are like highs.
Like, like knee highs.
Those are beautiful.
Kind of kinky.
Oh, nice.
A little bit of sugar in his step, dare I say.
A little bit of face in here.
Thanks.
A little bit of gold at the end of the rainbow, you know?
We're showing us the whole rainbow right now.
They're really doing it to us.
They're showing us his lucky charms.
And finally, risen from her slumber, debuting the face
reveal, the trash man, Snuffy!
Snuffy, you didn't shave!
What?
It's me!
I'm over here!
I'm winning!
I'm gonna win it all!
Wait, can you not hear the game sound either, Snuffy?
It's true, everybody!
It just sounds like you're talking in a room by yourself to
me.
Why isn't the crowd going crazy right now, guys?
Come on!
Everybody!
Woo yeah!
You're gonna hit the MC hammer?
Who's fucking tweaking right now?
What am I watching right now?
Are you gonna take off the hoodie or is it stay on in the
fight?
I think I take it off.
I'm really curious to see.
Oh yeah.
That, no, okay.
You shouldn't just put her back on.
Okay, here we go.
I gotta fucking win this.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're so not fast.
Snubby just handed the actual beat down on this man.
Slate head slam to the face.
And this dude is already reeling.
I don't know where Snubby's just under the table right now.
Am I slow casting this?
Fuck you.
Fuck you, big.
Okay.
I'm just going to go for these straight up arms snap.
Okay, now this is about to be the actual.
actual Richter floor scale earthquake right now.
Slip.
There's no way it's over.
Wait, one, two.
Okay, no, just a one count.
Just a one count.
It's not if you don't get too ahead of yourself.
You're not going to get them that effing easy.
But so far, this has been a one-sided beatdown.
I feel like I'm watching, I don't know, like, Michael's son
from GTA try and fight Trevor right now.
This is absolutely grim coming out of the effing gates here.
I mean, okay.
Straight for the nuts.
I mean, hit him where it hurts.
That's a street.
critical.
The cereal box!
Snuffy walks back to her corner and gives this man some time
to breathe only to come in with a rocket fist face slam.
I mean, this is ridiculous.
This dude's Mowalk is painted like a rainbow and his face
can be painted red soon.
It's Snuffy getting pinned?
But Snuffy, you almost got reversed.
Alright.
Looks like this man's trying to take out the trash.
And Snuffy really and this man is making a getaway just
kidding the animation canceled back into the arena okay and
stubby's going for the backbreaker gonna age his spine about
a few years and now she's tossing out the trash herself i'm
gonna i'm gonna eat you like an egg this is called hide in
the body she's going this one from metal gear solid and now
she's gonna pick them up and maybe like i don't even know
put them back down doing an Eminem rap song right now.
I'm going to do my signature move.
A trash growl, bruh.
We go.
I think you messed up.
Snuffy!
No, no, this is the- This is the build up.
Look at that.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Oh, yeah!
My man, it's sniffing the rainbow, but the back foot misses,
and he gets up.
Get a fucking whip.
Oh, shoot.
I feel like Snuffy might be getting wrong.
here she's getting taken out too again off the top rope I
think her spine at a 45 degree angle but this man is Jesus
Christ crushing in her chest cavity right now for you oh
wait it's not very good it's not very good and both of them
decide to make a mutual agreement to take the fight outside
of the exact same time but this man tenacious he stops at
nothing oh my god i'm just a wealthy match anymore this is a
brawl in the back streets of detroit okay snuffy's about to
take him and throw him back where he came from sending him
out of the arena himself oh god they're getting married you
can kiss the bride just kidding he's andrew tate and now
he's going back in he's gonna pick snuffy up now we're
entering dangerous territory ladies and gentlemen there's an
epic six seconds on the four more seconds and they're going
to be out I'm gonna win it oh okay not bad okay they're back
in the competitors are back in it's Monday that means it's
almost trash day I can't I can still win oh no it's getting
reset back to default programming right now I mean she might
go work at a trash compact drive this jobs over but she is
fighting for the ground to the nail she was just in a
Okay.
I'm going to gouge your eyes out.
Oh, God.
The key.
Oh, oh, oh.
Eddie's giving her some crazy action right now.
Even crazier action.
It's not me and do it.
No, she is not.
No, she's not.
And this man is so frustrating.
He got her number, but he couldn't get to fourth base.
So he's going to taunt her now that she's on the ground.
This is insane.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god, she's getting stepped on.
She's like watching an effing sub in real time.
I'm not talking submarine, ladies and gentlemen.
T-bagged her on the way through.
Picks her up and slams her down on the floor.
Oh my god.
And now this man is hitting an effing...
Haka Ranger?
Okay.
I think Snuffy just might be dead.
I'm not willing to sit in a call, Maverick anymore.
Wait, what's going on?
She's getting back.
I mean, I know vTubers are light, but come on, Snuffy.
Drop like a paperweight.
Holy moly.
Okay, this could be it.
Is he gonna do a backflip?
He just straight up misses.
You thought I was dead.
Oh my god, that's Snuffy's turn to turn around.
That's why I'm a paid actor, Fuyo man.
That's why I'm a paid actor.
And now I'm gonna make you eat dirt.
I mean, that was a devious elbow straight to his left
nipple.
I think that might be an epic another one to the left
We're taking serious damage there That's got to be bruising
Okay, the third team back of the fight.
He goes in for the single shot Snuffy counters and then
tosses him out like trash again.
Oh my god that looks like an illegal nut shot.
He went head over nut and he is down on the ground for sure
I'm just falling on top of you.
I don't have any special moves.
Oh god.
I'm gonna twist you Snuffy's just gonna break his neck.
You're gonna rip your ears off.
Some of these moves are getting down by illegal, ladies and
gentlemen.
In the night, they are busting out all of the moves.
Andy need to win this crown.
Oh, God.
Snuffy, you're fleeing the fight right now?
Just give me like...
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
The green goblin comes in with the effing green neck snap.
Snuffy's down for the count, but it's a good thing she can't
not get pinned outside of the arena.
might be dead right now oh my god that was my heart i think
it just exploded okay he just he's just sending her back i'm
getting yanked around like i'm feeling snuffy harry-pill
about the fight so far how you have so much endurance wait
the ball is off of the mat and she's actually getting
polarized
jesus christ somebody called dana white this is getting
Outside the scope of a fight.
I mean, I don't even know snuff.
You can get up in time.
We're up to six seconds ladies and gentlemen Two more
seconds maybe like oh my god.
Seven seconds No one they restart the count they restart the
count Head into the knee I mean snuff these notes have
become internal at this point You don't have any belly
buttons, but there's too many people counting on me right
now My senpai my master I won't disappoint them.
I can't God, after all the training I went through.
All right, Zuko Midori is kicking it in the gear to take out
Bakugo here.
I'm not sure if this is going to pay off, though.
Oh!
I'm going to show everybody my special skill.
She's heading into the London Bridge is falling down.
I don't know if this man can survive what's happening right
now.
I think Snuffy has 18 different variations of falling on top
of him, and it's somehow working.
Don't be afraid of the dark.
Dude, there's no way!
My god, this was so close!
This was so close!
Snuffy's about to say blood for the blood god.
Just give up!
The hammerer the elbow dropped.
I think Snuffy's saying my order was still raw, she wants a
refund on it.
I'm not really sure to take him that one.
Give me my drink!
I think three concussions in this fight, ladies and
gentlemen, and these characters are not really still in at
this point.
We're just watching cells of their former cells.
I'm gonna make your fucking brain.
A shamrock shake.
Oh, and Snuffy uses the fallen for the 18th time.
I mean, Snuffy certainly has a favorite move.
Let's fucking go.
Just call me fucking fall guys because you're about to see
this guy fall.
She had a backflip.
There's
no...
Oh my god.
For real man, you have the endurance of a god.
I commend you.
Come in with a hearty choke to the neck.
I mean, this is the fight that keeps on giving, chat.
It is like hepatitis.
These fires do not stop for anything.
Come here.
I'm going to show you why I take out the garbage.
At some point, I wouldn't be surprised if Snuffy grabbed an
audience from the effing stands to pull into this fight.
Use them as a bludgeon.
Oh, God.
I mean, this is getting serious business.
I see a kid in the front row.
I mean, I don't know if he can handle that.
Let's see what's happening right now.
They're back into the arena as we speak, and I think
Snuffy... Oh, God.
Oh, she oh I mean your man are you exhausted oh shit my
balls I don't know how these two fires are still standing
wait there's no way he says nothing do you like that you
like that she does not oh my god she's still in this fight I
don't even know how they're still alive.
This random nerd in the back is cheering for USA.
I think this man came to the wrong concert venue.
Oh my god.
I'm American.
She's a leprechaun.
Can Snuffy take out the luck of the Irish?
No, that guy said this is awesome.
Get alive.
Heck, he just got kicked through the rope.
I don't even know what's going on.
I just got my toe stubs.
Oh god.
What's happening?
Oh, please.
Wait, this is gonna be it?
Is he gonna go for the pin?
No, another power bomb.
Never mind.
I don't know what's happening.
The fireman- Oh!
A new move, ladies and gentlemen!
Oh!
That is a fractured elbow, and now he's raising the roof
like an F-ing 2018.
Oh, I don't know if my kid lasts.
I don't know if you can make it, but the Roar in 20s is
called.
They want their dance move back.
the top rope I imagine but he's really far away from snuffy
I don't know if he can reach oh my god and he turns her head
into a pancake I mean her IQ is definitely below 100 if it
wasn't before just kidding wait snuffy took our own self out
of the move
snuffy no you took yourself out and our winner it usually
isn't easy being green but today green has won it's for you
man yeah actually sacks and i imagine the wind tastes a lot
more like pennies holy boy destroy snuffy snuffy you there
oh god i have murdered a raccoon Oh, yeah, I got, I just got
my shit kicked in so bad.
I can almost feel that actor's realism.
He got his shit kicked in so bad, dude.
That was, that was insane.
That was an actual slobber knocker of a fight.
Yo, Mr. Fuyo, did you ever feel like the match was in doubt?
No, this is just a normal Saturday or Sunday.
I can't get the days right, but sure can't land his punches.
You gotta respect that, ladies and gentlemen.
man on a Saturday because on a Sunday he's already so
unpleasant meet him on a Saturday you might not even leave
to tell about it dang Fuyo man you put up a good fight it
looks like we settled the beef so uh snuffy are you gonna
rescind all of your statements you made against Fuyo I
always knew Fuyo was gonna be my biggest hurdle in the fight
and that's why I don't mind that I lost to them because I
feel like they're gonna go and win it all and it'll show
that I was truly at least second
all right those are acceptable standards that was a crazy
fight that was like 18 variations that people turned
themselves into pancakes I mean like I'm talking I hop at
that point yeah that looked like a waffle house at 3 in the
morning that was pretty insane we had the sort of energy and
stamina that I would like to say something normally in a
rapid fight so It looks like Ursula stole our interviewer's
voice, and then hopefully she'll return it any second now.
But, yeah.
So, anyway, what I was thinking.
I was mad at him!
I was mad!
Funo, man, please, before you go, please!
I must ask!
It's...
What?
It's a diaper med.
I...
Our first...
Our first match.
Ludo had a diaper in one.
You had a diaper in one.
What does this mean?
Please.
I must know.
It's a fashion statement.
It's...
Bro said belt.
They're reinventing the wrestling attire here by
mainstreaming the diaper.
Do you plan on rocking this diaper if you win at all?
What does that say about future wrestling?
The diaper stays on during the match.
Dang.
The War of Warcraft classic drip.
I mean, this person's aerodynamic and they are full of
utility.
God, Sam.
Snuffy, I must ask, was the person standing in for you?
Did he shower?
No, he never showered.
When I went through the interview process, he was probably
the stinkiest of the bunch.
I was hoping maybe if he didn't have, yeah, maybe if he
didn't have pure fighting skill, he might have just been
able to fumigate Fuyo to the point where she would not be
able to enter the ring.
It would be like a debuff, like a nuclear gas.
on Fuyo and Fuyo, does, Fuyo man, would you like to explain
what I'm about to say?
I believe the stench was matched.
Yes.
Wait, your stench maxing?
Fuyo man only showers once a month.
Of course.
My stench didn't bother Fuyo at all because they matched it
even with something even stinkier.
Discord mod sent.
A diaper.
A diaper?
Well, I'm going to be honest.
I think that was the best match of WrestleTuber 2024 yet.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to be honest.
I think it was the best one.
And I can't wait to see how far Fuyo Man goes.
I believe in you, Fuyo Man.
Let's go, Fuyo Man.
Yeah!
Non-bys.
Let's go.
Yay!
And now I get my co-caster back.
Da-ding.
yeah now i don't have to grow in the whole time i mean the
paid actor of course that was definitely not me getting my
ass i was not humiliating in the least that was all just a
paid actor all right i believe it's time for our next fight
are we gonna bring on our contestants is that how this works
wait a second since fuyo won does that mean fuyo sticks
around yeah fuyo is Fuyo man he's gonna take the whole match
wow alright and Fuyo man of course and Fuyo man's opponent
is going to be Nana than the lovely Nana yes the Nana that
destroyed the Giraud the pregnant dinosaur oh right yeah
alright well I can't wait to see when she when she shows up
on the effing set but uh Fuyo I mean are you gonna change up
your strategy this time around versus Snuffy Fuyo man
destroy Hatsune Miku?
Hatsune Miku?
Good morning.
Miku morning.
Miss Nana, are you ready to fight the Fuyo Man?
Oh yeah, let's go.
I have a habit of crushing small things on the earth.
You're calling Fuyo Man small?
Oh yeah, oh yeah, compared to the galaxy, all I see is a
tiny green snotty speck.
Oh, Frigo.
Fuyo man, destroy.
Someone just catches Shrigger on Fuyo man.
I mean, this is more accurate champ size right now.
This is ridiculous.
Fuyo man, big heart.
Yes, Fuyo man, you're very, very big.
Fuyo man is shrunk down to save their energy.
Yes.
I see, I see.
I think, honestly, the biggest thing here is Fuyo man's ego.
which I'm about to crush tonight.
I think that's a good assumption.
I think if Fuyu Man continues this match, by the time he's
done with his last match, he's going to doctor Manhattan
fucking delete the next guy.
So you need to put a stop to this, like a goddamn
supervillain.
Leave it to me.
I have history.
I have a complete resume of putting an end to many things,
including bloodlines.
So watch out for you, man.
I mean, speaking of superheroes, you guys are pretty much
the same size as Thanos and Ant-Man.
And we all saw that thought we could end up.
So any predictions today, chat?
Let's see.
Well, I think they're ready.
The viewers are rooting for Nana today.
Fuyo Man is closed.
They want to see Fuyo Man win at all.
But they also would like to see Nana bring in a win.
It looks like.
Fuyo Man, I have the ultimate question for you, Fuyo Man.
New York or DC.
Europe.
It doesn't matter.
Because...
matter because i will be sending your dead leprechaun corpse
to the national museum anywhere okay okay i'll be that's
where i'll be sending it oh my god he's gonna be a mask for
a man and dress just send her a coffin she's come to deal
business oh yeah you will need all the leprechaun look for
that oh yeah you're talking up the luckiest person in the
room right now that's pretty hard I'll take my chances.
Win out of pure luck.
She's got that manipulation going.
She's got the plus 10 luck skill.
That's a pretty insane logic.
Anything can be your downfall.
You might trip on a banana peel.
Why is there one on the wrestling list?
Luck, baby.
Life is a gamble.
Bring it on.
I think that's the great attitude to bring it on.
I would like to see this match.
Fuyo versus Nana.
Nana?
This is going to be good.
Wait, now you got me doubting.
It's it's it's it's Nana, right?
Or Nana?
It's Nana.
Nana.
Thank you.
Yeah, Nana.
No, no, no.
Oh, Nana.
There is a banana on the stage.
Nala, I've never heard that.
Wait, can I not hear the.
Okay.
Oh, I was like, I like the fit.
It's giving Rarity My Little Pony.
Very amazing.
Stop.
That's literally what Juna told me.
I'm sorry.
all the way from the cosmos of australia you know them as
the vanquisher of dinosaurs it's the galaxy it's not give
me some audio on the tv yeah and not doug we can't hear it
whoa okay an angel ascends down from the heavens i mean this
is absolutely magnificent the drip is insane This might be
one of my favorite wrestling outfits I've yet to see.
Oh my god, and she wastes no time getting straight into the
arena.
Quang on all fours like a possessed animal.
But this is not an animal.
This is the grace of a goddess.
She's displaying her absolute attitude and ownership of this
stage.
She's saying, Fuyo, I want to see what you have to bring
because I own this place.
There's at least 10 Discord moderators saying, please step
on me right now.
I can tell.
I'm one of them and I'm currently in her DMs.
Interesting.
Well, we're going to have to see it bar.
He's mean.
He's green.
It's the diaper-wearing machine coming back.
Fudaman!
I just had shivers go down my spine.
Yeah, the PTSD kicked in.
I think...
Oh, my God.
The way he looks.
I hate the way you look.
The way you talk.
This mean, green, killing machine has already shed some
blood today.
will they be back to return that favor will they still have
the stamina to take another win will they show you guys why
i died and it wasn't because i'm unskilled truly we're gonna
see why nana will put up a good fight i'm sure we might be
able to see nana pull off a win here fuyo's fuyo man is
tired he's yeah that's what i would say right like fuyo man
just came out of an effing grueling fight i mean you see his
chest it's red and sore it's swollen nip slipping i'm lie
insane pepperonis there with eyes they also have eyes i see
i'm not sure what the context is but all right let's go
straight to the fight i nana not gonna take it down an
instant lead on this nana is taking control of the situation
she's lifting oh my god on that back what was insane a
little bit oh fuyo takes advantage of that sloppy landing
nana might have gotten ahead of Is it going to be a close
line?
No, it's a collision.
Head-on, 40 miles an hour train versus 40 miles an hour
train.
That's not taking control of the situation with an amazing
dead drop there.
Oh, my God.
And just mind-gaming the situation here.
Whoa.
She just pulled Fuyo's signature move on himself.
She jumped over his head with a tea bag.
I mean, that's a taste of his own medicine.
Oh, but she's got him by the beard.
Whoa, bringing Fuyo Man down to the ground.
Oh, the Fuyo Man's got it with a straight kick.
Kicks from the floor as well as beard grabbing.
I mean, this fight is already off to an unkempt start.
Fuyo.
Oh, my God.
Really showing those bar fights coming in handy here.
Oh, my goodness.
Going for the weak spots right on the elbow there.
That's going to throw Nana in for a turn anytime they want
to set up some moves.
Oh, Pup.
I mean, Nana's kind of taking a beating early into this
fight.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah.
Fuyo Man is leading quite strongly into this match.
Oh, yeah.
But Nana is turning the moves back around in her favor.
to her oh she's got the beard again leave the man's face
alone she's insane remove the flesh and bone go nana go do
what your body is telling you remove the flesh oh sorry i
got a little caught up in the moment and she should have
called him popo but i don't even think she needs that guy at
this point she is just delivering the smackdown on all
levels right now oh but fuyo interjects with another low
blow i've elbow to the eyes there that's a little that's a
little Oh my, Fuyo with another low blow.
See, Fuyo is just interjecting with these quick little jabs.
And Nana will turn it back around and be like, you know
what, this is what real skill looks like.
Let's see if she can do it again.
Oh, and see another situation where a trained professional
meets somebody who's only learned through backyard brawling.
Yeah, I think Nana has a lot of, you know, openings in her
defenses.
She keeps getting kicked in the head.
She might have to look out for that weak spot.
Nana has some professionalism.
Oh, but that's the most powerful.
like she's here for sure wait one oh fuyo man is not so
quick to give up as we've seen with our match fuyo man is a
dedicated insane stamina god oh but you know i did realize
the reverse flying oh yo man took off the diaper for this
match so could this be the loss is this loss i don't know
Oh, my.
I mean, I think you're just taking her to abuse us.
I've seen warheads slam into the sides of this ring than I
have my entire career so far.
But she's getting picked back up, and she's stunned.
What is happening?
She's just dislocated Nana's arm kick bone.
She's being sacrificed like Abraham's own son.
Her neck is about to snap.
Oh, it doesn't look like...
Oh, she can hold her.
Oh, she takes him off.
They're both hurt from that move.
Nana, turn it out around in her favor.
A weak drop.
She misses her kick there.
I don't know if that's going to be...
these wrestlers behaving like they're at least six drinks in
right now not even sure if they know who they're fighting
anymore at this point oh my god not only burping him cannot
burping him like a baby boy let's see if nana can keep the
lead oh but fuyo could turn it around what is this oh my god
she got him in the ham sandwich they turned into an ice
cream sandwich for that maneuver again nana really does not
have good defense when she goes for grapples it's a common
word what wait she's down just turned that around on her too
oh my oh my god just like that an instant turnaround foo man
sweep nana must be green with evie because moving on is foo
man it's a second final row snuffy we witness foo man do a
reversal on one of the opponent's signature moves to take
them out he is a counter god he's i knew fuyo man was gonna
take the lead and win it all i told you guys that his win
would be ominous philian are you gonna step in here is it
will you be seeing fuyo man in your matches i might have to
at this rate i'm kind of scared though i mean this guy might
have a contract with phase clan because this dude can
counter strike for sure i i don't know i don't have that
okay but let's take him back to the casters or the
interviewers oh my god small but mighty and strong enough to
take down a fucking galaxy nana what do you have to say you
were talking big mad shit do you know what i'm actually not
too mad because guess what who yo has to go against at least
three other people from my dead agency and so the will of
the tragedy continues i may fall today but you will go
against all those who come after me good luck for your man i
was literally invoking all nine members of the one for all
legacy right now i don't know what's going on the effing
entire plan over your head what is on our head what is going
on ladies and gentlemen this man has jumped into her hair.
Fuyo man, destroy.
Fuyo man, are you ready to reenact a fucking Christmas carol
because you're about to ebonize or scrooge this company's
last members.
Are you ready to win it all?
Are you going to fight the ghosts of VTuber past, present,
and future?
I will learn her.
I see.
He has learned well.
That was a victory with no diaper.
I would like to put that out there too.
Fuyo man did not wear his signature diaper that match, that
means that that wasn't even a fraction of his power.
Kindness is cool, Pansu.
Kindness is very cool.
That is actually Fuyo Man's real underwear, by the way.
It's true.
Yes, I acknowledge your drip.
Will you be selling it after this match, Fuyo Man?
Only if money horrid.
Get your licensed merch.
I need an adult.
Undies.
You'll win every match you ever enter.
I got a secret.
Oh.
Oh my affiliate is dead.
We're so back.
We'll come back.
I'm back.
One second.
I'm not actually Thanos snapped the wrong person.
Please.
I have a right on God's greener to walk around.
For your man, what are your next opponent?
It's a bit scary.
Are you ready to raid her dungeon?
Yes.
For your men raid.
For your men destroy.
Come on, Omia, Emma.
You have to avenge me.
You have to avenge me!
For Prism and for Therulia!
For all of us!
Stop the leprechaun!
Stop the Irish!
End them!
Stop the Irish end them!
End quote.
Let's fucking go, Fuyo, man.
Your life ends 10 seconds from now.
Let's see if that's true.
My final message.
All right.
Well, we're going to go ahead and move Nana out of here.
Thank you so much for competing.
Thank you so much, Snuffy, Philly, and Doki, and Ryo and
Juno.
Thank you so much.
Bye-bye.
Goodbye, Kola.
All right.
And we're going to bring in our next competitor.
Somehow, she looks even bigger right now than the other one.
it is going i mean jay i mean bigger in a lot of ways she is
up and she is ready for combat it is Emma miss Emma oh what
what she's asleep ringy ding ding oh my god you're watching
starting who's there disturb my sleep what where is the next
opening that's why he was here wiki wiki emma emma it's time
for you to clob or someone are you ready for this challenge
i know you just woke up no one over here are you ready to
kill somebody somebody where yo fuyo speak up fuyo speak up
you might have to speak a little bit but fuyo man fuyo man
destroy holy shit what is that thing oh my god miss emma
miss emma fuyo man has won two games in two matches in a row
do you feel intimidated i don't know i cannot see him down
there can can you climb fuyo man of course what does attack
on hiden climb to is not the only thing that can climb on
those ropes in the match there's other things that fuyo man
has sealed it escalating yeah escalated the funny questions
Wow, Fuyo man, you are so bold.
I respect that.
Emma, does Fuyo man feel good?
Fuyo man feels very good.
The three inches.
Since you are so small, I'm going to smash you with like
really gentle, okay?
So I'll make sure you don't cry and pee in your diapers.
I'm feeling some weird tension already.
Fuyo man.
Okay, Fuyo man, we shall see about that.
You're trying to like warm into submission before the match
even starts right now?
Because it seems like the charm isn't working right now.
Mind games is exactly what sends the mental for victory.
Yeah, and this guy's a stronger mental game than Michael
Scott.
I don't know.
Mentally quiver and shake is exactly what you need to make
them waver their faulty strength and confidence.
Make Fuyo Man doubt why he's on this stage.
Make him doubt why he was ever in this career.
Oh no, it's working.
We're manipulating him.
Fuyo Man, you always wanted to be a doctor.
Remember what your mother said.
What did that mean?
Fuyo Man, doctor.
Good gaslight.
That's amazing.
Well, Fuyo Man is about to perform an elaborate examination
on his opponent, Emma today.
Amma, are you ready for your examination?
I am super ready.
He can inspect me whenever he wants.
I see what he finds.
Sounds like we should get to it.
Ah, frick.
All right.
These two fighters are coming up.
We're going to see how this goes.
Dude, I feel like his opponent just keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
First, do a snuffy.
And she's like a normal size.
of human right and then after that nana and now a little
like like i don't know how many more titans this guy can
take down many different shapes and sizes you're barely
you're barely telling us to get above the casting fence
winning back to back he's mean he's green you know him it's
for the third time this man comes out spinning in circles
and hitting poses?
Is he going to take a dump?
And there it is.
And now he's ready for combat.
Oh my goodness.
He makes the crowd quiver.
Everybody's at unease.
They don't know whether to root, cheer, cry, celebrate, text
their loved ones.
They don't know what's going to happen.
But Fuyo Man is going to make it freaking legendary.
I just want to see what's under the hat at this point.
I'm really curious.
What's he got underneath there?
The man.
the myth, the legend, the leprechaun, Fuyo Man taking the
stage, showing off why he is now a two consecutive win
winner, and perhaps maybe even three today.
And returning all the way from her dungeon, it's your final
boss, but will it be Fuyo Man's final boss?
It's a...
Wow!
And she comes out with Majestia's Frick.
She looks like the final boss of an Elden Ring franchise
game.
She is intimidating.
Lady Royalty herself, Emma, about this show.
What this doctor's appointment will diagnose us with.
Absolute queenship here.
Look at that form.
Look at the professionalism.
Look at the posture.
This bitch is here to win.
Her jewelry kind of looks like a collection of weapons.
I don't know if she's going to be allowed to keep those on
during the fight.
But, hey, I mean, they made custom.
rules themselves so we'll see how this goes down oh she's
she's above getting on the ring herself you will you will
let her in you will be appropriate here you will let a lady
into the ring no one is dead all right slowly the crowd oh
my god she's working the crowd right now someone in the
crowd just passed out yes take her crown take her throne
take care of it while she's away killing the fight begins
now Fuyo Man versus Emma Chad who are you rooting for who's
gonna take it all the three-time Fuyo Man win or will Emma
upset the match let's find out oh I mean this inspection is
his fist with her face but she kicks him in the nuts so she
knows a thing or two about anatomy also and she just slammed
dogs up I think the fight's over never mind this man gets up
how is this possible Emma has been watching Fuyo Man's last
match as she might be able to know how to mind game Fuyo Man
to a win here.
She's studied his moves.
She knows his routine.
Oh, but that might not be enough.
She's reversing the karma on her, disrespecting her in her
own game.
Fuyo Man knows a thing or two about psychic damage himself.
Fuyo Man is at the top of his game right now, and he's
showing why he is right now WrestleTuber 2024's prodigal
son.
I mean, yeah, this guy's on Fing CSI Man.
He's most wanted right now.
This dude...
Oh my god.
He just clipped her skull through three different layers of
rope.
I mean, that's got to be some quantum physics involvement
right there.
He almost just shattered the game devs fabrication of this
level.
I was where the whole game was in a crouch, but this guy's
getting mounted and beat into a pub.
I mean, he's doing the Omniman versus Invincible in 40 years
speech right now.
Jesus Christ.
He's getting flipped over, stared at.
I, okay, getting rid of like a piggy bank.
No.
Yana's starting it off strong.
She's not even letting Fuyo Man have a chance here.
Oh, but Fuyo Man is signature with the jabs.
You know that's his trick move.
Whenever someone gets on top, he finds a way to get out.
He knows, yeah, whether it's the knee, the foot, or the
elbow.
He's always quick with the jabs.
He counters.
And now he's cranking the hog.
Oh, my God.
For the fans, that's for sure.
And Nana's going to get back up and see if she can handle
this.
I did this wrong.
He's getting pinned.
My man got every scorpion.
wasn't even close not even for a second i mean wrestling
this is looking more like a cuddle match at this point can
we try a little bit more aggression oh my goodness stop
kissing in the bedroom and telling i want to see some
bloodshed i want to see some bones breaking fuyo man destroy
the stands are back up puts her down he's going for the
elbow shatter that's a really strong move it can break a
ligament i think i don't know yeah oh fuyo man aims to put
every the count he does not want to see them at work
tomorrow he wants them to be calling off he knew she was
leaving the arena and he caught her out oh my god oh yo man
countering every move emma throws out that's insane oh my
god of the stairs and she's back in the arena i think she's
hoping for a timeout foo yo man i mean there's only three
seconds composure together okay seconds give me a little bit
of time to okay and there he goes yep Is composure fully
filled now and instantly slamming her head into the ring?
Oh, but Fuyo Man can't get ahead of himself.
She's no setback.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Oh, Fuyo Man.
Always quick with the counter.
Oh, my goodness.
He's going to the crotch.
And he's not letting her go.
The crotch grab.
The personal grip.
5,000.
Oh, my God.
Donald Trump can take a page out of this one, but he's going
for the pin right now.
Phew!
Another quick Fuyo!
Oh my god.
I thought he made quick business and jam out of her, just
like the last match, but no, Emma's gonna show us what she's
made out of.
Is he going over the tea bag?
Oh no!
It could be jam and Fuyo man spreading it on his toast for
breakfast.
I think she's dizzy.
She's dazed.
I don't know just how much...
Oh my god, she's got abducted in reverse, and she's getting
picked up.
Toss on the ground.
This is gonna be a pin.
No, it's gonna be a curbsaw maneuver.
eyes across from with a soup man punch is that lights out
two oh my god she was the one second away from putting down
fuyo's reign of terror and now she's staring at him like an
animal survivor i okay but he oh my god he's quivering he's
shaking he's begging if this goes up for much longer you
might tap out but not quite the fight still goes on dude
that could have been a serious timeout okay and she ran to
put her pits up to the nose, but Fuyo Man said he smelled
worse.
Oh my god.
She just dropped her entire body weight on him, and she's
going to do it again.
She said, take a whiff of this.
Oh my woo.
Oh, she didn't have a really good minimum.
She spared him.
She's just skipping over him.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
And Fuyo is showing why you don't skip.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm watching a John Wick movie right now with
the amount of exchanges that are taking place right here.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
What was that?
She just did some sort of Tekken move on him.
That was insane.
Sun kick, I believe.
I saw that one in Naruto.
And this man climbs up on the poles just to get beaten down
by her even more.
Just can he reverses her?
It's about to snap her in half again like a Twinkie.
I, will you get the move all complete?
He's not sure if he can get the footing here.
Can he make it off?
Nana's fighting back for sure.
Oh my god, just tiring her out?
What was that?
I don't know.
Stretching her body like a masseuse?
I mean, this dude's performing like a sumo wrestler right
now.
Fuyo man is wanting Emma to beg for forgiveness.
Oh, and he's not done yet.
He's about to oh no.
Oh no.
Oh no, the Fuyo signature.
She's in a pin.
One, two, Emma fight!
Oh no, no, no.
It could have ended right there.
That was so close.
But Emma seems to be fleeing the arena again.
She's pouring herself on the outside of the wires.
If she gets punched, she could fall off.
The reversal.
counters i'm at his own game one could it be two no fuyo man
is not a quitter i mean every single count goes to at least
two nowadays it's only gonna take one moment from the hit a
three count at this point both yeah they're both on the
ropes here this is this is getting close literally oh wait
that's the whole point of the thing but they're gonna go in
and snap his ankle i don't even know what happened i think
like he is feeling it emma has definitely done some damage
here i think he might have crippled him oh my goodness.
Oh, she shoots high on the head kick, but apparently it was
so intimidating.
Fuyo's falls over anyway.
I believe in Emma.
She's got some fierce kicks, and those shoes don't look
comfortable to get hit by.
She's grabbing Fuyo Man.
This could be it.
Fuyo Man cannot counter this.
There's no cheap shots here.
Oh, and she's making it so.
Emma knows now what Fuyo Man's game is.
She knows how to win.
She knows not to give Fuyo the upper hand by getting a
counter option here.
here let's see if she can win it here the chiropractic
spinal repair just came out of her now she's doing another
chiropractic i mean this guy's getting adjusted from the
inside out somebody get fuyo man's physician on the phone oh
and he's still in the match holy moly and now fuyo man's
running for his own life it might be his turn to flee out of
the arena for once but i mean he gets a good hit on emma
flips her over oh my god i saw bread i saw blood I think
this might be it, ladies and gentlemen.
Emma, might be on.
One, two, three.
Three.
Fuyo Man wins three times in a row.
Fuyo Man cannot be stopped.
Back to, back to, back your winner.
Kindness is cool.
I think Fuyo.
Man is a great leader to take this match.
Buoyo Man making insane waves here right now.
Three back-to-back-to-back sweeps here.
Buoyo Man is on fire and does not look like they're letting
up at any point.
Who can stop Buoyo Man?
Who can take the win?
Yeah, I mean, some people out there, they say Ronaldo's a
goat.
Some people say Messi.
But to me, Buoyo's my goat.
I'm not going to lie.
I mean, this man has been on an absolute rampage.
He's just torn through three people.
I don't know.
faster than like geez an effing born a china shop i mean
this man is a force of nature uh let's bring it back over i
think in a little bit to see how uh this post game breaks
down for your man sweep holy shit how are you feeling after
that match no way this can't be i lost to a little guy
I wasn't supposed to be this easily defeated but he's too
powerful maybe because he's too green I can never defeat a
green guy he's like a Hulk to me that's it dungeon red is
close no one can come in anymore I'm gonna go take my rest
gonna respond gonna go to chiropractic and everything gonna
enjoy the nature but I'm gonna be afraid of green no I'm
gonna stay at home I'm gonna cry oh I hate green green is
horrible man your response kindness is cool green is cool
soil men destroy i must say emma how did it feel having this
tiny little three inch here all over you a what a little
than your next julio is more sanitized than dwayne the rock
johnson and he's winning just as much this is crazy emma
don't be afraid to eat your green finish might make your
match a win next time don't worry fuyu man is a legend
though and i'm excited to see what more he conquers in this
wrestle tuber 24 whoa vegetables are horrible just like fuyu
man it's okay for you man i wish you um suffer eating
vegetables forever like it's your veggies
take my rest dungeon rate will be closed for a week for a
month for a year for the decades fuyo man is banned in my
dungeon no more fuyo man dang how does it feel being one of
the first finalists for the wrestle tuber a normal sunday oh
wow i i love that confidence I guess Emma loves a man with
confidence.
No wonder she folded.
He is very confident.
Even though it's the exercise.
Alright, well, uh...
Wait, so what do we have coming up next?
Are we, um, snuffing?
Do we know?
It looks like our next match, I think, is with...
Is this Luto again?
Luto running it back?
I'm not sure who his opponent is today.
Let me see.
Let me check.
Let me check the broadcast.
We're getting word that it is Luto versus Anan.
Anananananananan.
Anan.
Who's Anan?
They look mighty saucy, though.
This is going to be a good match.
Fuyo Man finally getting a well-deserved rest after a three
back-to-back win here.
We might see more wins from Fuyo Man, but for now, we're
starting it up with a different match today we have luto
versus anon non non non i believe it's non we'll have to ask
them themselves what their preferred pronouns are we'll find
out here dang what is this luto luto you are way too dressed
up to be fighting someone to the death right now i mean you
look extravagant oh yes oh what's that wait hold on what
okay that was non i believe no yes oh my bad i got too
excited wait a second who are you i'm not i'm not you
impersonated someone a master of impersonation i would never
interesting all right and we have also here luto yes luto
welcome back we'll come back so what are your records so far
in the tournament guys how you guys done so far is it like
one and one i believe luto maybe have what has won two luto
is it true one or two one one okay yeah both are at one win
so this is a pretty this is a pretty interesting match we'll
see who's truly stronger here then to win two matches rather
than one were you just lucky or is this a true test of skill
let's find out well how you feeling i just I cannot lose
you!
I cannot fucking lose you!
I'm trying to spirit bomb right now.
I mean, God, power of animated China on her side.
I better see you beat me hard than Luto.
If you dare.
I'm gonna sit on you with my stinky diaper and you ain't
gonna save!
Do it!
I dare you!
And also trust me while you're at it!
Okay!
Fuck yeah!
I know, that was so bad.
Oh, good.
You guys are all diaper abusers.
This might be a fight to remember, Chad.
Our talent here, they are fierce.
They are fire and they are ripping each other apart in the
backstage right now.
What will that say about the match?
Oh, I'm excited.
How are you?
Dude, I want to see how they murder each other.
I will murder her right with my ass.
Oh, yes.
Wait, can you bring in a weapon too?
I'm not condoning any of that.
Yeah.
I have my tail.
Is that good enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hit me with that too.
All right, okay, I got you.
I got you, remember.
Oh, thank you.
I mean, no thank you.
That's gonna be awful.
Absolutely.
I wouldn't want that.
I also don't want to hold hands of you in bed and gloveless.
We're going to change the title of this stream.
X.
All right, all right.
Oh, I can do that.
I thank the gamers for sponsoring today's stream.
Make sure to use code Snacker to 10% off at the discount
section.
Whoa.
What?
Let's get to the fight.
Let's go.
All right, Snuffy.
Here it is.
Crash says dummy versus the thing.
I'm not even sure who's going to win at this point.
I could not tell you which one is which.
Now let's see him kill each other.
True.
I believe none is going to be the one with the bunny ears,
but let's see it.
In this corner, it's the diaper from hell.
The spawn of the demon lord himself.
The crimson devil.
It's Luto!
Absolutely extravagant.
This guy's just Fuyo born on a whole different level of
Zesty.
I mean, this person's coming in for the effing crown.
It looks like they got their horns from a CSGO loot crate.
I mean, there's a lot of effing bling bling on this bad boy.
You know, I almost want to see it.
I feel like somebody, this is somebody who truly rivals Fuyo
Man's energy.
If anybody was to bring Fuyo Man a decent match, it could be
Luto.
Luto might be able to match the swagger of Fuyo Man.
But we will see if Luto has what it takes to win it all and
see him in the ring.
Or will Luto collapse and we'll see another hero rise to the
occasion in the form of Nyan.
Why is Luto wearing a coffee filter around her neck?
I believe that's an old Victorian tissue for sneezing into.
See?
He just did a really epic stretch.
strategy just like and then you just look upwards and it
just absorbs the entire radius of the so they can wipe the
blood off on it it's similar to the diaper yeah it's
basically luto is going for a full versatile equipment
standard here and making their way to the stage all the way
from Wonderland hopping into the ring it's no no no no dang
I don't know what's going on but this is like a nothing you
Chihawk clan member the outfit not giving us a bit of sauce
here I like the face on the ass very iconic she said I know
where you're looking and meet my gaze oh yeah we're making
not entering the ring my grandma she probably smells like
her too i imagined at least like death now oh a little bit
of sauce not is looking pretty confident coming into this
fight i'd like to see her stir it up she's got one win under
her belt so this is not new to her i do like the purple gas
that's everywhere it makes a little bit more mysterious and
maybe even smells like peppermint but we'll see whoa she
might be a rabbit but she's behaving rather cash Okay.
Let's see how this is vital.
I don't know what to respond.
Wait.
Let's get it started.
You see that chunk?
The diaper is back on.
It is.
I mean, these people kind of look like Five Nights at
Freddy's characters, but they are already delivering the
animatronic beatdown.
Oh my god.
a walmart children's bicycle but she is delivering like a
semi truck absolutely and i i thought like at the first like
non was gonna be in serious danger because of the size
difference but i mean no one knows her angles and she's
already doing some big damage on ludo's extremities i mean
she might take down her weak point one by one like johnny
apple c cutting down a tree oh my god it's a brains over
brawn type situation here i think philly and oh my gosh not
might be smaller speed and swiftness with this skill oh my
goodness she's already got him wrapped up in two oh there's
no way two guys this way would have been insane but ludo's
already fleeing the arena and non wants none of it this
person will stop at the end of the earth and kill you a
little front whip oh i think her face is caved in i don't
know ludo does have the diaper so if she shits the bed early
it is going to be able to save her that could be the play i
guess we'll have to see and not is taunting at the crowd oh
my god she got his feeling confident and she got the hordes
she played with the bull and she got the hordes having to
stare down the century not disrespectfully gets back into
the arena right in front of luto doesn't give a single freak
in the world alpha giga chat energy coming out of her and
we're going up on a tuesday not is keeping the segue of this
fight strong in your favor oh and i say that right as she
loses her cool the rock star split slam oh my god ludo going
for oh how many ads can they take up beating this much like
ludo is treating non like a game of hopscotch oh my oh she
won't just stop fucking jumping i mean she does know her
weight is her greatest asset it looks like in this fight Oh,
and Nod is getting the actual beat down put on her.
Underneath, over the top, picked up, and slammed.
It's just a break of her ankle falling down on top of her.
Oh, my God.
Flip comes out of nowhere.
Stoke into the pin.
Steam into a swift.
Oh.
I mean, Nod might be indestructible.
They're small and dense.
It's like an effing black hole.
I assume that that gets us the second count.
She's still raring and ready to go.
Let's see what she has to show right into the crowd.
Oh, and a little bit of fan service for the people.
The guy that got a full head of hair there.
Oh, my God.
Maybe even a kiss.
Oh, and some blood on your pants.
Oh, my God.
The Joker flip on the ankle.
That was kind of insane.
But it looks like that was a reversal exactly that Ludo
needed.
Just kidding.
These two are getting dirty with it.
I've never seen the maneuver in my life.
This man's being folded in 18 different directions.
I'm like watching human origami right now.
She's got her strangled right now.
Absolutely.
But she's plunger in those veins.
Oh, she's got her in the eyes.
We're at six seconds because she's getting back in there.
Every possible resource to stay alive this match.
It could be over.
Oh, and Ludo is getting high off the crowd's energy.
Let's go.
Oh,
and the energy is fueling Luto like a battery.
She's like a vampire sapping after the energy.
The crowd is fueling her.
Chat is going crazy.
The whispers.
I think Nona's dead.
Nona's dead.
I think Nona's just dead.
Some brain activity, signs of life.
Luto's coming down to finish the fight, I guess.
Oh, oh, Jesus.
She's not down yet.
She just needed a minute.
Wait, Luta's on the...
Begging for Luta was a fool to give her the time.
True.
Are we going to the stands?
No, we're not.
You have been cast or desk right there?
That's you and me, Snoppy.
You see us over there?
Yeah.
But it looks like they're not going to be visiting us today.
Unfortunate.
Still stairs could be...
Oh, my God.
We do have a fine table for you.
Oh, and she's got her by the hair.
Oh, my God.
is absolutely killing her i'm watching killer instinct
unfold in real time what's happening she's getting abducted
back into the arena oh my god non said i'm not done yet i
don't want this match to end i still have something to show
said you don't want none of this a murder slam in the face
down i he's just staring at her again did they just high
five each other okay oh my god oh counter punches.
Nod's taking two, three, and she's out.
Oh, my God, and it's non-stop.
She looks like she can't drop and thunder.
She's just jumping on the back and shaking her.
But she's still going.
The arm bar, the arm bar?
I don't really know what that maneuver was very effective.
You can't just held on her fingers.
And the screen has gone black.
And Lucho has... What just happened?
No!
The turner Was that a technical foul?
They reset back to neutral?
Jesus, what just happened?
Lucho just mind-wiped the entire crowd and reset the match.
No way!
Devil mind tricks.
True.
The whole person is a really effective ability, as it turns
out.
I think Na might be out.
This could be it.
Na doesn't even know where she is anymore.
Oh, no!
This could be the finisher!
Oh!
What is hell out?
not allowed for that this is like probably flying and we're
back to playing hopscotch with her oh my god using her body
like gravel oh i don't know if not gets up from this one non
is not looking good i believe i'm seeing a little bit of
blood here even this this is a gruesome one oh my goodness
it's a slaughter luto is not letting up it's not okay no in
the window to loot oh holy moly the diaper meta is real your
winner is loot oh
my god someone get this one on an effing taylor swift track
this guy's got long suit um let me see let's go back to the
audience or our uh casters for the post interview i'm having
ready for this junk snuffy did you the diaper meta to really
make it to the finals twice wait no it's just one match from
the finals right i almost there i'm surprised you know i i
guess i would say i was hoping for a little bit more of an
upset here the last couple matches have seemed pretty set in
stone but i'm excited i think i think nothing is more hype
than to see two strong components combine each other into
one epic fight battle well what's here for luto and non
what's up guys how's that fight looking die for murder
non how does it feel to not just get beat up by one of your
co-workers but two of them let's just say i came for the
match and i came from the match oh it was great i feel like
i just lost something well i must say luto you you've been
your stamina is insane i but i i like you'll have are are
there any opponents that you're looking forward to fighting
oh yeah i'm ready to bring the irish man down sorry that's a
tall tree to cut down i mean this man has been unstoppable
exactly three different we need to get this do you have do
you have any plans on taking down fuyo man luto i think i
think whoever is think he gets to take it home right so
Oh, that's classified information.
I can't give you that for free.
Well, you heard it here, folks.
Luto is indeed horrendously stinky.
I'm covered in benchling.
I can't lose these.
All right.
Well, I'm still in the fight, too, so don't forget that.
It's going to be me versus two diapers, I feel like.
And maybe someone else, I don't quite remember.
sell clothes bins with our final match tickets with how
stinky our wrestlers are my goodness well uh any further
words snuffy before we send it back over to the main desk i
think that's everything that was an amazing match by you two
what insane skill thank you both luto and non for an amazing
fight let's take it back to the main desk thanks okay thank
you wow okay wow that fight was that how you thought that
was gonna go wait who were you rooting for wow guys that was
an insane fight you know i realized when uh fuyo man was
actually not supposed to do a third fight in a row because i
missed up the order but like at this point fuyo man deserves
that buy in the final bracket because we were supposed to
send emma and fuyo man to the final bracket but you know
fucking row.
Fuyo Man deserves to buy.
I did not expect Fuyo Man to travel this far.
So, now that I believe we finished all our brackets, let me
bring the brackets up onto the screen for all of you guys,
so you guys see what has happened.
So, as you guys know, oh, I got some fancy graphics going in
for all of you.
Alright, so we have uh wait saiyu did not win so let me get
rid of saiyu's card all right luto proceeds here and she
does the teleports behind you undertaker special so i guess
she travels all the way with phillian in bracket i know it
says phillian versus luto but if you guys didn't remember
everyone that makes it to the finals here in their bracket
actually gets reshuffled so I cannot be bothered to realign
this, but if you guys didn't know, like, Philean Luto might
not even face each other.
We are going to be spinning a wheel.
We are going to spin a wheel to decide who exactly they're
going to be fighting in the end.
So we have Philean Luto making it in to the final brackets.
We don't know who they're going to fight, though, yet.
We're not sure yet.
So that is the results for bracket two.
Bracket one.
Fuyo man ends up getting the buy Who to send my finals
Because I made a mistake
So let me grab put in Let me put in the bracket number one
for you guys for the visual So as you guys know we have Fuyo
Beating Nana and also beating Emma So Fuyo man automatically
gets the buy to the semi-finals because I made a mistake and
at that point Fuyo Man won three times in a row and they
deserve that win if you win three in a row you might as well
get into the semis automatically so whoever wins their last
the next match in the final bracket will be facing Fuyo Man
finally um okay also for those who need a visual.
Bam.
Here she is.
Here's Fuyo.
So you guys can see it in the visual alone to see how it
goes.
And there she goes.
And then we might as well just put her over Emma because she
beat Emma.
So we know only one person is advancing in bracket one.
Finally in bracket three.
We didn't have any matches in bracket three because we
actually finished bracket three on day one.
But we'll show you guys who they are who made it into the
final bracket.
Let me pull up bracket three boom and then get rid of foo
real quick it is sarah and betta so sarah and betta are
going to be heading over to the final bracket and finally so
how are we going to decide this like we said um we will be
spinning a wheel uh of names of all the people that made it
to the final bracket and i do have somebody here as i
mentioned earlier today on stream that's going to be helping
me uh helping me spin the wheel she'll be it'll be like that
that game that wheel of fortune game no what was it yeah
wheel of fortune game where she'll spin the wheel for me and
then we'll see who it is are you in the room are you in the
room my other person.
Yeah, I'm here.
Well then I am kind of lost.
Well then.
Just like a real goat.
Am I good?
Do I need to move?
Where do I go?
She sneaked her way in.
What are you watching?
I'm back.
She sneaked her way in.
Were you watching some of the videos?
the games been i was i was watching some of the games which
one was your favorite one um i don't know i think uh foo
man's kind of crazy you i i know i see foo man in the alley
i i don't think i'm gonna make it i don't i think i'm i i
would actually just i would kill myself first i'll be like
i'll do it for you i'll die by my own hands yeah i mean it
makes sense it's real man like i i'd agree anyway so we got
our little wheel here i haven't wrote anybody's names yet on
the wheel um so give me a sec as i put you know give me a
sec give tell me some of your favorite moments man while i
write the wheel write the names in the wheel okay i was half
also have eating my spaghetti so um let's see uh what
happened oh gosh you just talk about real mad if you want to
i'm completely prepared as a caster thank you um i've heard
a lot that there's a bunch of diapers going on oh that's
true that's true did you plan that doki oh why why would you
say that like what was me about me and diapers I don't know.
I just feel like just like this vibe from you.
I don't know.
This diaper vibe?
Yeah, so there's a bunch of diapers going.
I think, what is it?
Phyllian's going against some diaper people.
Well, we don't know yet.
She might not be, though, from the wheel.
Oh, true.
The wheel.
Yeah, the wheel decides who they're fighting.
Am I missing a person?
I think this it could count as the wheel of the worst the
wheel here we go it's time to spin that wheel oh yeah yeah
when we really only need to spin it twice to be fair because
like we got the automatic buy but all right here we go
spinning that wheel we going against flio no it's who's
going no feel gets the buy in the semi-finals so it's gonna
be luto who is luto gonna fight We're gonna find out All
right, who is Ludo?
Ludo's either gonna fight Phileon, Betel, or Sarah Ludo and
Betel will be our first match in the finals bracket Which
means Phileon will be fighting Sarah in the next fight Okay,
she avoided the diapers.
Yeah, she avoided yeah but whoever oh that's true that's
true because like whoever wins the betel versus luto will
have to fight fuyo man so like so that there won't be two
diapers fighting each other in the finals oh man yeah so so
uh yeah and then like um and then i guess like wait let's
pull out the let's pull out the brackets here so we can
order this up let me pull it out where is my image here i'm
Very professional.
You always are.
I mean, I know.
I know.
I mean, of course.
Yeah.
So, Sarah will be, okay, this will be where Fuyo got the
automatic buy.
And then Sarah and Philean are down here.
And you see this, right?
Yeah, I'm watching your stream.
It's a little delayed.
There's a little delay.
Okay.
And then there's Luto here.
Luto is going to be fighting.
Beto down here.
And then Fuyo gets to automatically advance.
So Fuyo will be fighting whoever wins in the Luto versus
Beto.
And then Sarah will be fighting Phillion.
Yes.
Alright.
Okay.
But we do have a problem, Mint.
We do have a little problem here.
What's that?
Is that we are sort of missing two fighters at the bottom.
what oh yeah i think i did it yeah i did like a little
miscalculation mint oh okay wow that's so i'm brand free she
can't she can't count you guys yeah yeah yeah okay look i
mean i was i'm gonna say like you were you fucking like
broke into the arena out of nowhere and even though i had a
security you killed off all our security guards like Like,
what was I supposed to do?
I'd spend the night hiring a new security guard.
Fuck your face, bro.
You're a ghost.
I know, I just, like, you know, they were looking at me the
wrong way.
I don't know what to tell you.
Well, it's a good thing I hired a new security guard to
tighten up the security.
You wanna meet him?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, yeah, sure.
All right, camera, guys.
Bring in, bringing our new security guard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Matara!
Wait, what happens to the security guard I hired?
I'm gonna fight you, I'm gonna cook you, I'm gonna eat you,
I'm gonna kick you, I'm gonna punch you, I'm gonna throw you
on the wall, I'm gonna pick you up, I'm gonna twirl you
around like a little princess.
Ugh!
Okay.
Mint.
Doki!
What did she mean by that?
I'm gonna eat me or I'm gonna eat you?
I don't know, what does she mean by that?
What did you do?
What didn't I do?
Did you you did you bring her over here why is she trying
why is she trying to kill all the security guys i might have
told her that we were like having a coup you know like that
we were that i was just like hey wouldn't it be cool if we
like you know did our podcast from from the wrestling
stadium but this one was it was already kind of taken you
know but we had well i guess we Another match to make up the
brackets then.
The podcast Battle of the Century.
Mint versus Matara.
What's funny is that, like, she's not actually here, here at
the moment.
No, she, she, like, said, hey, I'm going to go on vacation,
but I'm still going to kick your ass.
So she said, she said a, like, a spiritual form of her.
So to kick Mint's ass.
ass and she still killed my security guard so she did it up
yeah she did all that she needed to do yeah like she so
unfortunately unfortunately um now there's no more security
left in wrestle tuber so but we don't have any crashes after
that i'm pretty sure right just come on in everybody just
come on no do not come on in everyone do not come on The
door is wide open.
No, no, no.
I will start selling off Doki's socks, okay?
Again, what do you mean again?
I didn't say again.
Oh, I said this again.
Oh, did this happen before?
That's what I'm saying.
I was like, what has this happened before?
All right, guys, before we go off to our final bracket, we
are going to have a 10-minute interview.
her mission.
The next two matches will be casted by Kai and Octavio.
And I believe there will be a Phelan match.
So Phelan really wanted to cast her own match.
So we'll have her jump right in with Kai and Octavio and to
cast with them as well.
Anyway guys, we hope you enjoy WrestleTuber so far for day
two.
And Mint and I, we will cast the final matches after Octavio
and her own match against Matara, her spiritual form of
Matara.
Hey, she's not here.
I could whip her ass.
I mean, she's fine.
Wait, what do we do if, like, will you be voicing for
Matara?
Yeah, I'll voice for Matara.
I'll voice for Matara.
Okay.
All right, we'll see you guys soon in 10 minutes, everybody.
Don't go yet.
The finals are going to be here soon.
See you there.
See you in a bit.
you
oh shit sorry let me sorry the intermission was wild oh
sorry we needed a couple extra minutes
anyway welcome back welcome back to day two of wrestle tuber
i hope you guys had a nice break during the intermission.
You're able to stretch your legs, get hydrated, walk around
a little bit because it's already been almost three hours of
WrestleTuber.
Wow.
Yeah, time.
Yeah, time really flies by.
Oh, a noticement.
You've got headphones.
You brought it from home?
No, I made these.
I ripped them off some guy's head and I spray-painted them
in the back and, you know, just like how you kill that
security guard yeah i hope you didn't pay like a like a
security deposit or anything because you're not getting that
oh it's all right it was minimum wage it's okay it was
minimum wage anyway everybody so we will not be casting yet
me and it will not be uh casting yet instead when it would
be a matara versus mint then we'll rotate in so the first
the first casters going in for the
Octavio and Kai Paging Octavio and Kai Are you guys ready?
Octavio and Kai I'm ready Do you guys even remember who's
the next matchup?
Oh, Jesus Yeah!
You do it this time I said it last time You say it this time
It's Battle!
Hey!
It's Battle and...
Yeah, yeah, I know Oh, it's over.
It's over.
Oh, yeah.
The demon.
The demon Luto.
What's your full name?
There we go.
Arakaluto.
Are you reading from my OPS right now?
Is that what you mean?
No, totally.
No, no, no.
Totally not.
All right, guys.
So Minna and I will be muting very soon.
So we're going to take it away to the next casters.
Good luck, guys.
Good luck.
Good luck!
Hey!
We are back!
I got a big head again.
What is this?
Help me!
Hello?
Oh, hello!
How are we?
Hello!
How are you?
You're about to face someone with a very stinky diaper.
Listen, listen.
I have something very brief to say.
I will not stoop to this thick and twisted diaper meta.
today I fight as a man not as a baby you just say that
because you're scared of the diaper of course I'm scared man
scared of the diaper what are you you see what they're doing
people out there it's terrifying oh yeah oh let me sit on
you anyway oh my oh my god listen I said I've been watching
I've seen teleportation I've seen, I've seen green monsters.
I have everything stacked against me.
I'm just a man.
Got any lost die words, my dude?
Yeah.
What?
No win.
Yeah, no way!
I take this thing all the way.
Oh, man, I don't know how you're going to win without the
diaper, but I'm looking forward to see how this match is
going to go.
I don't know.
I'm not convinced, man.
Okay, everyone who's had a freaking diaper wins, man.
I'm scared.
True battle.
I'm out of the middle.
I hope you brought a diaper.
No diapers for me.
We're going commando today, baby.
What?
That's sad.
Because when you shit yourself, they're all going to see.
You know what?
That's fine.
Shit into the air.
That's great.
We shit like men, not cowards.
We don't need diapers.
Can't wait for that chocolate fountain man.
I shit in the light.
I don't hide in the shadow.
You expose it to the sun god.
The sun god.
The world will see.
Man, God isn't real.
God isn't real.
I have no words.
These two are the craziest, most unhinged people I've known
for a bit, and I'm very scared.
I don't, I don't, I have no words.
I don't know what else to ask, honestly.
I'm scared.
know what's crazy when even the fucking interviewer is like
fucking shaking like oh my holy man what the fuck i'm gonna
win that's all you gotta know i'm winning i'm sitting on you
i'm watching you with my ass this meta ends today the energy
in here is kind of stinky out of me please take this away
please okay all right we'll save you all right let's see you
get in yep gotta see which ideology diaper no diaper will
win today in the ring
oh my god you know what it's kind of weird that bettle kind
of looks normal compared to luto yeah i was just about to
say i had to like blink and like process his fucking face
for a second i was like wait hold he's just wearing oh no no
no here yeah bettle has that double face thing going on he
has a painted face and his own face dude i love how his eyes
are like spread out so he could like see everything he's a
real anime man yeah he's looking at things like every every
angle bro he sees everything
yeah wait we'll see we'll see if um the non-diaper believer
will win against a diaper meta-believer yeah oh holding true
to the diaper meta it's your underworld spawn
it's luto yeah oh i love her oh there we go i see it i see
Just a vibe.
Vibing.
True, true.
I can't believe we started the freaking diaper thing.
I know.
Now it's been applied to everything.
True, true.
That's just, again, the pure power of the diaper.
It's strong, okay?
Yeah, Luto vibing the demon from hell.
Hell yeah.
You know, this fight is more than just a fight between
wrestlers.
Oh yeah.
It's a fight between an ordinary human and Gavis Behron.
and the demon race.
The demon diaper race.
They're their own breed.
Then they shepherd.
True, true.
Who are you rooting for here?
Wait, do you think that Luto's like the diaper demon queen
then?
You think she's queen?
You think she's on top?
Yeah.
I also noticed that she keeps her diaper intact with a pin
in front.
With a gigantic pin.
True.
Yeah, I remember.
Did you see that?
Sayu bringing that up before, yeah.
I think if she were smart, she'd take that and, like, stab
his eyes out.
But, you know, that would be against the rules, you know.
And opposing the diaper.
It's the jester with the silver hair.
The most charming baby girl himself.
Battle!
Let's go!
That's my senpai, the weirdest senpai ever.
Oh, come on.
He's a jester.
Oh, my gosh.
just called him like yeah he's weird but i love him and he's
great he's a man the representative of flat supremacy let's
fucking go dude that face is just terrible holy shit also
the fastest intro in the business yeah he's all business
hell yeah he didn't come here to play man he came here to
win oh yeah here we go both of them are high flyers actually
now that i realize it i i wonder the first like fucking
jumping attack i'm waiting those are my favorite okay oh
drop kick on the face but it wasn't enough to like to drop
her oh damn wow oh dude the advantage here keeps changing
who's winning battle or luto i can't tell oh they keep
missing they keep jumping and missing ah there we go
battle's just freaking agile what the fuck oh shit one oh
okay no no no no that'd be Come on, get up, buddy.
Get up.
Betel here has the makings of a champion.
I'm sure he can recover.
Oh, no, right in the balls!
Right in the face!
Balls!
Balls in the face!
Betel's most important parts!
Oh!
Body slams from the top of the rope.
No face, it's over.
Oh, no.
Luto is going crazy.
Luto going feral.
Oh, he trained my back butt!
No!
Was that the balls or the stomach?
Damn, Betel.
Oh.
You need to add 300 more pounds to your weight.
Yeah, I don't know.
To make this match even.
Flinging him around, like, way too easy.
Rue it.
Oh, head to the mat.
Okay.
Reversal by Betel.
That's great.
Oh, yay.
One of Betel's signature flips.
Hell yeah.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Headlock.
What's he doing?
He's setting him up.
Setting him up.
Throw him around.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
The fake to the throw.
And a pin.
One.
Ah.
Don't count battle out just because he's 200 pounds less.
That's what makes him so agile, right?
He's made out of skin and bone.
Oh, no.
That slam was insane.
And now a submission technique.
Break his leg!
With the legs.
Dislocate it.
Oh man.
No, he can't get up.
He can't get up.
Oh!
Right in the nuts again!
What is this targeted attack on the nuts?
Oh my god, wait.
Setting him up again.
Again, bro.
These elaborate setups are so pretty.
Finally, it's going to work in his favor.
Is he going to do the fake?
Another flip.
Oh, but it didn't work.
Oh!
But he still got her.
kick to the stomach.
Another one.
Oh, I love it.
That's my favorite.
He loves that flamboyant flair.
No, come on.
Ooh, on a one count only.
This is still anybody's game.
Honestly, Beto can be dropped by just a single punch.
Dude, I don't, I don't know, man.
What happens to Luto if she removes her diaper?
I feel like.
It's like those are power limiters, right?
It's like rock weight in the fucking weights, all right?
Take out the diaper.
She needs that.
to fight in a normal man's wrestling match.
Oh, what?
The referee bumped into Luto?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Get pinned down.
One.
Two.
Still not.
Still not enough.
Oh, flip.
Hey, look at those flips.
That's my Oshi.
Two.
Oh, almost.
I'm scared.
Dude, Betel's kind of going crazy right now.
Oh, he removed the turnbuckle.
What's he planning?
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Another flip, maybe.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh, no.
The reversal on Betel.
Oh, no, dude.
Right into the announcer's table.
Just too long.
Oh, no.
He's going crazy.
Betel's going to go feral now.
Oh, no.
Right on the 7th.
Ah!
Get back in the ring!
That's not just one!
It's three!
What?
Gonna do the three suplex combo!
Oh man!
Come on, Beto, you were doing so good!
This is so sad!
Oh, in the taunt!
Oh, you're really gonna take that?
Oh no, in the taunt, let my boy go!
Let my boy go!
Let him get up, man!
Let him get up!
No!
Oh man!
Come on!
Oh!
stepped on the chest two inches deep straight to the heart
he's gonna get palpitations after dude what happened oh my
god but what i'm sorry he can't he can't breathe after this
how how is he supposed to breathe after this the his ribs
like multiple rib fractures now yeah he got the flail chest
he's gonna die this is not a referee move out of the way man
trying to see the action oh my god this lady the way the
referee That's going to result in concussion.
Flip.
Rainy right in the butt.
And the favorite flip.
It's your favorite flip.
Hell yeah.
I love it.
Looks so sick.
Okay.
Oh.
Damn.
The backbreaker.
What is this?
No, the surprise pin.
Oh my God.
Not like this.
Okay.
We're safe.
Oh, no.
the diaper into the face.
Oh my god, I thought she was going to sit on his face.
Oh, you can hear the squelch from here.
Oh, dude, the stick.
It's filling up the arena.
Woo.
Betel still has a chance.
Oh, no.
A kick to the back.
Oh, come on.
Just kick the diaper off.
He's going to remove the turnbuckle again.
Oh, God.
He's removed two now.
What is he going to do about it?
Fucking slam, man.
Fucking flip slam me out.
Oh, my god.
He can't just body slam normally.
He has the flip.
Yeah, I got out a little flare.
Oh my god!
He uses his body as a weapon of fireball.
Dude, he's a fucking weapon.
He needs a permanent walk around.
Humanity will not give in to the devil and Satan.
Oh, the taunt.
Oh, but battle didn't like that.
Oh, headbutt right to the ribs.
This is what you get for taunt.
There was a cool spear.
though it was it was oh this might be it this might be it
one two two oh come on it's still anybody's game oh another
what's he doing oh i thought oh come on do the jump come on
finger guns finger guns come on do the flip you know you
want max luck and broke his ass he missed failed that little
Oh, what is that?
No, you're gonna fucking kick me in the ball?
That's illegal.
Think again.
The illegal move.
I can't believe it.
With a low blow to win the match.
Your baby girl is all grown up.
No diapers for the winner.
I can't believe it.
No.
I can't believe what I'm seeing.
That was so, that was beautiful!
Oh my god, I have like a tear in my life.
Oh man!
That was great.
Ladies and gentlemen, battles the motherfucking winner!
Oh, we should be What a sad, what a sad move.
The dirtiest move he did.
I didn't know Luto could lose like that.
Dude, I didn't think it could get dirtier than the diaper,
but here we are.
I- yeah.
My fucking bulls!
excuse me you can't you can't talk to a man on his balls
like that i thought you were fighting like a man not like a
chicken well if i remember correctly you did it too i didn't
go for the balls i was just matching my opponent so what can
i say i i bettle i need a note of thought process of
grabbing luto's balls why why did you do it listen to defeat
your opponent you attack the source the diaper is the source
you will go for the heart the diaper heart was it was it
warm was it warm oh it was warm but it was not as warm as my
burning passion was it big enough for you at least ah yeah
it's a match but i will not lose its size
the goff lesbian who would have thought that the goff
lesbian would win you know what little you're pretty
confident but i don't know it ended up not paying off kind
of sad to say i thought the diapers were the key but it
wasn't more like uh more like loo still oh my god my god
he's so funny oh you're so funny i'm gonna i'm just gonna
call you cock grabber from now i'm ball I will wear that
title with pride.
Ball grabber!
Ball grabber battle was made today.
The myth, the legend.
My brain can't process this right now.
It's too late for me.
The great grabber of balls!
Battle wins!
The more you say it, the more I question my life choices.
His name has BNL.
Which is present in balls.
Wow.
That's so true.
So that makes sense.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah, so true.
So true.
I need to get a raise.
Cool.
I need a raise with this shit.
Jesus Christ.
Well, congratulations, Betel, I guess.
Thank you.
Hi.
Congratulations.
Hey, that was a great fight.
Thank you so much.
Congrats.
Even though it was really dying.
For that amazing, amazing performance.
No scopes are insane.
Never forget.
about it i'll never forget good you just you just started
ludo's villain arc right now
one day everyone will know the wrath of the diaper queen one
day they will
battle's gonna go against the fuyo man oh dude are you ready
are you scared yeah i am yes you are you are gonna be up
against fuyo man i went why did i win oh my god i don't know
my battle versus the leprechaun gotta get out of here that's
a match for the centuries wow yeah i am so i'm ready for
fuyu man to next beat him up all right now we're going on to
the next do you guys know them maybe yeah who's fighting
maybe yeah kai will you be able to tell kai knows what no
you know kai knows what what you said Nina, you said their
names before.
It's it's let's say it together.
It's it's it's it's it's it's and and Sarah Sarah yes how do
you feel about the castors not knowing who you guys are?
Wait, what happened?
Wait, I'm not animated anymore?
Did I get fired?
How?
Yeah, you got fired.
My budget!
We have budget cups, sorry.
I can't afford it anymore, alright.
I'm indie now, what can I say?
It's definitely what it is.
Alright, like, who am I up against?
Sarah?
Oh, it's a snake lady.
Oh, look, look, Philly, and you probably don't know who I
am, but I don't really care, because I have a philosophy and
it's pretty simple.
I'm gonna be so good that they can't ignore me.
So that goes for you, my opponent, goes for the audience,
and goes for everyone.
Because, look, people might not know me out there they might
not even like me but i don't need to be liked i need to win
so i'm gonna play the villain if it means i get that yeah i
respect it yeah i remember the pilot is very spicy today
you're the one that killed dokey bird aren't you i am i am
bogan i casted you yesterday i saw all of your moves i
observed them anything you do i can dodge you understand me
You've learned from Dorky and you think you can take me on
now, huh?
Yeah, I'm gonna take you on.
I'll just kick you in the nuts.
Learn that one from battle.
So, yeah, you're pretty much downloaded and you only took up
one gigabyte on my hard drive.
I'm sorry.
Kick the snake in the nuts.
Oh, uh, yeah.
I think you'll find that anatomically incorrect.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know, you could kick Sarah in the nuts, but
she's got a whole fucking snake, right?
and then she'll just yeet that snake like right how do you
counter that grabbing the snake by the balls too true yeah
true the more you listen i will avenge toky i will flip on
your face and i will beach into a pulp i will take your
teeth and remove the venom from them and then i'll sell your
skin as a purse understand me right but uh i'm not
necessarily a venomous snake i'm one of the types that will
constrict you so um i'll have you tapping before long let's
uh let's just say that i don't care what your kinks are
what's up you get down those fights i i think i think
they're well at least there's no kinks in here yeah they're
ready we accept we accept all kinks here very accepting
environment we love that all right we gotta throw them in
the ring we gotta throw them in the all right who do you
think is gonna win man i don't know it's a difficult one
phillian is a high flyer both bogan has a snake you can't
fucking do she's got a snake man like i don't know i don't
know let's see if she can pull off what she learned from the
battle match thankful that she won't bring out the snake
during the battle usually she brings out the snake at the
end that's true we'll see but who knows maybe she'll change
her mind
the serpent that doesn't take shit from anybody.
The serpent's storyteller herself, Sarah.
Oh,
that harmonizer.
Where is she?
Sarah.
Her sweet ass time.
She forgot the snake backstage, all right?
She left it in the break room.
Fuck you!
Where's Sarah?
Where's this damn pilot?
Don't tell me she got cold feet!
Oh, there she is.
There she is.
Let's fucking go, Sarah.
Look at those tight shorts.
They're very tight.
She's got so much muscle.
Holy fuck, fucking bill.
Holy crap.
I'm not quite sure.
Is that hair or like a...
No, that's hair!
Yeah, that's hair!
It's actual hair.
I thought it was like a thing, like a cloth.
Oh, okay.
No, no, no.
It's her hair.
She takes such good, like, such good care, you know?
It's like, so flowy.
Oh my god.
Crawling on the floor.
That's intimidating.
Immersing herself and what it means to be a snake.
Dude, I don't know.
I feel like half of these intros are so intimidating.
I'd just be scared shitless.
I don't know how Phelan's gonna deal with all the diapers,
man.
She's just gonna have to, like, shit on, I'm sorry.
I can't get over the diapers.
man I can't it's the end of an era I need to get over it but
it's it's it's stock man I can't I can't accept reality I
mean diaper diaper meta our legacy that's our legacy as cast
is for today I love it you bet next year's WrestleTuber will
have a bunch more diapers yeah no next year's WrestleTuber
everybody's obligated everyone diaper Russell diaper
everybody has a custom diaper yeah and you can buy merch in
the future, right?
Oh my god!
No, not the merch!
Dude, actually, though...
No, no, no.
Actually, no.
No.
I'm just kidding.
Actually, yes.
If I had a diaper, I'd want it to be dazzled.
That's useful.
Diapers are useful.
It's true.
It's also the Great Equalizer.
All of us wore a diaper before.
That's true?
Yeah, true.
I'm sure dragons wear diapers.
Well, I mean, maybe when I was like a wee dragon, but not
anymore, because I'm a big girl, obviously, and I'm very old
and wise, because, you know, I'm like a god, and I'm like,
oh, like that.
When we're super old, like geriatric age, we will wear
diapers again, so.
No, no, no, dragons, we're just, like, built different.
Sorry to say, so we just don't.
We're just better.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I see.
Yeah.
I see.
But maybe you could be the first.
Who knows?
Right.
I can't start a movement.
Set the trend.
Yeah, trend setter.
This intro still just goes on and on.
It's been an hour.
But bugging.
All right, there we go.
Get out of here.
Thank you.
Here we go, guys.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Here comes Phelian.
And making an appearance outside of VR chat here to grace
our presence.
It's failure!
Yeah, yeah, yo!
Look at those moves.
Yeah, I love those moves.
I don't know what those moves are called.
Yeah, no, me neither.
I don't know what any moves anyone's making today.
I don't know wrestling moves.
I don't know dance moves.
Oh, do you know, Octavia, do you know how to hit the gritty?
Yeah!
You do?
It's like, I do this.
See that?
Get it!
Yeah, that was really impressive, man.
I'm also impressed.
Don't, um, I think I need more practice, honestly.
Me too.
Philly, you should have done the gritty.
Zero out of 10 intro.
Yeah, what the heck is this dance?
This dance is actually very like, very old.
This is what the kids do nowadays, all right?
We're doing like 2008 dance.
When were we hitting the gritties?
All right, this is your old.
Get out of here with that shit.
This was the year where we all had eyeliner on.
It's that old.
I just want to hear about hitting the gritty.
gradient skibbity toilet that's a okay here we go i don't
know i don't know how to bet my money on bogan i don't know
too though i kind of want to oh oh oh oh whoa all right that
just like those signature phillian flips i can't wait to see
what goes on here what's what's bogan strategy i think bogan
is a high flyer there we go bogan's pure strength yeah i was
gonna say he's muscle exactly whoa just rode on philian the
poor little casually is that a cat casually breaks your
spine ouch oh oh the flip oh oh damn whoa the people's elbow
damn but bulbo gets very aggressive stick in the landing
every time that's inaccurate philian seems to be moving at
times two speed Yeah, I was just about to say that.
She's looking so fucking speedy right now.
Oh, my God.
She got that Final Fantasy haste spell on.
Yeah.
Or drugs.
I don't know.
She ran out of her A game.
All right.
Oh, a pin already.
One, two, two.
Okay, I thought that was gonna go for it.
That was like too early.
That's too early.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, what are you setting up?
What's going on here?
Are you setting up?
Oh.
Yeah, she's like, get out of here.
Flip!
Ah!
Oh man, that was so cool.
A drop kick to the back.
That's got a hurt.
A herniated spine.
Come on, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
Oh, butt to the face!
Oh, so lucky!
A non-diaper butt to the face!
So lucky I should not wear a diaper.
Just straight up like bone structure and fat.
Oh.
Flip.
Ooh.
What?
That was sick.
Props to the cameraman.
The cameraman is doing great.
Dude, right?
Unlike this fucking referee that drives me through the roof
every time.
True.
Whoa!
Fucking Satan down another one!
From the ring!
My God, how does she not get dizzy from doing all those
flips?
Oh.
What was that?
Okay.
Ah, right on the cement.
Come on, get her, get her down, get her down!
in front of the crowd.
Look at all those three men in the black shirts.
Crowd is so excited, so hyped.
Okay, keep him inside the ring.
So you can pin him when you need him to.
Get in the ring!
Oh, they're staring each other down.
One in heaven, one in hell.
Oh, oh.
Oh!
Holy shit, do it!
Just carried like a twig.
Do it!
Oh, head to the turnbuckle.
That's got to hurt as well.
Whoa!
Huh?
You didn't tell me Bulk Bogan was also athletic and flexible
like that.
I got the setup.
I know she did that as well.
Oh, here we go.
This referee is so freaking slow.
Two!
I know, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Fillion is too slippery.
Too slippery and thin.
Yeah, she's too fast.
She's too fast.
Oh, butt to the face.
Again.
Oh, pull her arm off.
Pull her arm off.
Yeah!
Crap her by the ear, yeah!
I just realized Phyllian is in like a generic dance practice
outfit.
Yeah, she, listen, she's not here for the bells and
whistles.
She's getting to...
Yeah, no, she had a warm-up, all right?
She was warming up.
Oh!
Phyllian actually rivals Gavis Battle in all the acrobatics.
Maybe even better!
I need to see Phyllian versus Battle fight just for all the
flips, dude.
Oh, shit.
Oh, kick in the air.
Converse to the face.
One, one, two, three.
Not yet.
Now, this seems to be, this feels like it's going to be a
long battle.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Why did Ludo just like dramatically like her all up?
Like, oh, God, get it.
Oh, she set herself up for that one, honestly.
Her own butt to Bulk Bogan's face, bony.
That's gotta hurt.
Oh, the ankles.
Oh my god.
Oh no, I can't.
Bulk Bogan is...
I can't watch.
This is just...
Ludo, come on.
Yeah.
Get it together.
What?
Bulk Bogan, your snake!
Think of your...
Ah!
An elbow from the top of the rope to the cement!
What?
Oh my god, Philly just won't let her get up!
Phelian, don't kill Bulk Bogan!
Her snake won't know what happened to her owner!
Oh god!
Oh, what?
The snake is waiting at home for Bulk Bogan and she never
comes back.
That's so sad, oh my god!
Snake, we're, yeah, we're, listen, we're putting the snake
up for like auction.
Everybody put your, put your auctions in the chat, how much
are we, how much you want to buy this snake for?
We need to find a new owner for Bulk Bogan's snakes.
Damn.
Dude, I feel like they should already be counting like Ludo.
It's just like not getting up.
Oh, no.
There she goes.
She's not done yet.
She's not out the fight yet.
Okay.
Don't let her treat you like that.
Oh, yeah.
The reversal.
Let's go.
Oh, right in the gut.
Oh, right in the face.
Ooh.
How do you block an arm that thick?
Dude, you can't.
She's just a fucking tank.
whoops oh whoops yo oh what am I watching the rest of our
Olympics dude these flips are insane feelings in the wrong
place she should be at the fucking gymnastic Olympics all
right not the fucking WWE but it's not on me to one career
path three this is it that was it billion one against bulky
bogey holy The furry speedster straight out of your chat.
No, not Sonic the Hedgehog, but it's Philean.
Yeah!
That was insane.
Dude, I thought she was going to whip out that snake, but
she didn't.
Ah, she should have done it.
Well, Philean, all of that gym, all of that workout for
what?
Philean, why are you flexing?
You have nothing there, bro.
You look like a toothpick.
Why are you flexing?
It's all right.
Listen, I can't talk shit.
She fucking won.
So it doesn't fucking matter.
It doesn't matter.
Muscles actually don't matter if you think about it.
All right.
Let's go see what they have to say.
That's just in-bone and tendons.
Philly and Philly.
How the fuck did you, like, how did you raise him up?
How could you flip him?
I need to know.
I used the power of God in anime and I showed her my snake.
And it was over before it began.
Like I said, new purse.
Is it a Pada?
Is it a Gucci?
No, it's a Sarah.
All right.
I just have one thing I want to say.
And my name's not Sarah.
It's not Luto.
It is Sarah Nagare.
Remember that name because I'm coming back.
And I'm coming back with a vengeance.
You better believe it.
This is not the last time you've seen me.
So remember it next time.
Hey, hey, let me know when you can touch your toes.
All right.
What?
Snakes don't have toes.
All right.
Well, let me know when you put them on and then touch them.
Oh, whoa.
I put them on.
I feel like- Let me just get my fake toes and I'll- I just
find some feet.
I'll just find some feet, like, strap them on real quick.
It's like Velcro, you know?
Yeah, I'll just, I'll throw them on.
It's okay.
Wow.
I didn't know Philean liked feet.
We're learning a lot of things today.
Hey, no king shaming, no king shaming.
Hey, I'm not here for the feet.
I'm here for the snake.
Give me Jin.
I'm keeping that nerd.
I want his little mustache.
Oh, God.
True, he does look very distinguished.
Yeah, I just realized that he's very distinguished.
He's very gentle.
Yeah.
Wow.
Sara, because you did fuse with Jin.
Does he have anything to say?
Yeah, I don't have something to say.
And that is, are we allowed to swear on this or is his
family friendly.
I've sworn a bunch of times so I mean I don't know.
At least if you get in trouble we get in trouble together so
do it do it.
No I'll be I'll be good to everyone.
You fackers I'll be back and I'll be snaky than ever.
You just watch now I'm gonna get these snaky dogs out and
you're gonna be facking licking them next time.
Oh my god.
You know what I'm looking forward to your We'll remember
those.
I'm so immersed.
I'm so immersive.
Oh my god.
All right.
Well, I believe now we will actually be rotating casters.
So thank you guys for your crowd battle.
It was fun.
What a great fight.
It was.
Congratulations, Billy.
Yeah.
Congrats.
I'll carry on your legacy.
You and Doki's.
Thank you.
Philly and you've got my you I'm ready to go away.
I know I don't like this.
You're supposed to be me I'm sorry.
I'm still in my I'm still in my friendship.
Yo, Sarah, you have me on my PayPal
What's going on?
Don't worry Hey, okay, so we're rotating castings behind the
scenes doki.
I'm gonna kick you guys off the fucking casting table now
leave goodbye hey snap them and they're gone and then we're
gonna roll up now it's our show now it's our show now yes a
huge thank you to kai and octavio for casting um that was
their last match to cast and now it's just mint and i left
for the final couple of matches and Are you excited, Mitt?
You're going to be fighting the spirit form of Matara.
Oh, everybody needs to be ready.
I'm ready to pull out.
I'm not afraid to bite.
I just have to say that.
It's sad that, like, Matara just can't really...
Oh, yeah.
I'll speak for Matara.
Don't worry.
You'll speak for Matara.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, I got it.
Okay, here's a...
We're starting with the, you know, the rough talk, right?
Yeah, yeah, go, go, go at it.
Hag, fight, hag, fight.
Okay.
Matorikon, you are a bug and what do you have to say about
that?
I am a bug and I have a lot to say about that.
I have...
For you, man?
For you?
You know, this is Muttar Khan.
This I've always sounded.
I didn't realize you were related to Fulhaman.
Muttar?
I think I might be at this great, great, great descendant.
That's why I'm also so ugly.
Oh, what do you have to say?
to mint matara i have to tell her now i hope she uh kind of
i hope she eats my flesh and i i that's what i hope what
that's uh wow no the only foot you'll be eating is my foot
matarika
interviewer are you not gonna ask more questions interviewer
i I I I feel like I'm out of place.
I'm gonna be honest.
I feel like I'm very out of place I shouldn't be here.
Goodbye.
You do not have to do your job.
Ask her some really tough questions.
Yeah, yeah, ask Matara some questions.
Yeah, yeah.
Any questions?
You what?
I I need I need to know since since you're not physically
here, are you are you technically like a ghost spirit as
well so it's like ghost on ghost fighting ghost on ghost
action god that's a really great question um why are you
laughing why are you laughing
i think batara's choking
Anyone know the hotline maneuvers?
She's joking.
We need to remember right here.
We need to get the electric pulsage.
She needs to come back to life.
How are you going to beat?
I forgot to.
Yeah?
What was the question?
All right.
But Tara, how are you going to beat men?
Yeah.
I'm going to probably first, I'm going to show her my boobs.
And I'm going to show her my butt.
and them shall be too embarrassed to fight me anymore oh
damn my personality is shit so it's all I got I need to know
now mint are you like ass and boob I'm an ass and a boob ass
is life and boob is hometown are you gonna go ham on her
boobs I'm gonna motorboat the fuck out of the I'm gonna I'm
gonna get in there I'm gonna get on them nice and juicy I'm
gonna I'm gonna get in there I'm gonna get in there real
good
oh well I guess we gotta take to the ring then so she can
make her dreams come true
whoa I forgot to kick them off on the stage too give me a
sec Whoops.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
He's taking a nap.
Yeah, you see?
We had to drag him out of the room.
He had a rough time.
All right.
Oh, Mitch, how do you feel about fighting Matara?
Oh, my God.
This is my first time seeing the bottom.
We contacted someone to secretly make a wrestler for Mitt
and Matara.
Told me that.
I was like, you're going to Enjoy Oh my god, it's so good
Alright, I saw the intro you're definitely gonna enjoy Oh no
Okay She's hungry Her big meaty claws are ready Flying in
her cockroach stunt double It's Matara Khan Oh my god, where
is she?
Whoa, she has her wine She brought Red Solo, Red Solo Cubs.
I totally did.
See, she's not here to fight.
She's here to party.
Yeah, she's here to party.
It's mom time.
She's got her wine ready and she's ready to party.
Look, she's showing off her butt to everybody.
Her boobs to everybody.
You're not exclusive.
Oh, she did not see that camera.
Those glasses are not helping you, Matara.
grippers.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
For free?
Oh my god.
She's showing everything.
Look at that dance.
Is that what she's gonna do to me?
Because meow.
Whoa.
Which part?
The feet or the...
Oh.
Damn, calm down, man.
There's plenty of Matara to go around.
Oh yeah.
I mean, I actually don't even know what the size differences
are in the ring.
It'll be interesting to see.
All right, there you're coming up.
Evil beware, you're in for a scare.
Projecting herself onto the ring is our own ghost maid
dressing up as solid snake.
Meant!
Oh my gosh, she took off her jacket.
Oh, there you are.
I like the, I like the little, yeah.
Oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Where are you looking at Min?
Oh, I, I'm just, I'm observing the situation going on here.
Okay.
Calculating right now.
Yeah.
Those map equations in your head.
I'm, I'm seeking out every exit of this building after it
explodes.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna blow it up.
Oh.
You're observing all right.
Oh, I don't actually wish What are you?
That's a hundred thousand dollars of explosion right there.
Yeah, and I've got an ass to beat solid snake Turn around.
I mean it.
Oh Wait That leaves nothing to imagination Not at all Like
who am I?
Call my name Say my name!
Mint, mint, mint, mint!
Loud!
Mint, mint, mint!
I can't hear you!
Oh my god, I'm growing, I'm growing huge with power.
Give your, this is your spirit bomb.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, she's gone.
Make sure she's doing her stretches right now.
Oh, I'm so laid back.
I'm ready for this.
I'm so ready.
It's fine, I'm getting her defenses low.
I mean, you got the feet right up to your face.
She ain't wearing any shoes.
It's okay.
You know, the bigger they are, the harder they fall, right?
What did she do?
What are you going on, B?
This is so rude.
She's doing her mom dance on you.
Oh, my God.
This is a Fortnite avatar.
I know I look like Snake, but go.
I don't know.
I don't feel very confident anymore after that.
Oh, oh God.
It's fine.
I'm gonna I it's it's the it's the Lord Farquad cut Okay,
they did me dirty
I mean, I mean you're so hopeless she brought you back to
the ring Oh, I win it on my own.
Thank you very much Oh, she missed those glasses are the
wrong prescription Matara Everyone has the same sign in the
background.
There's like 15 people.
I'm here for you.
Come on, get up, Matara.
Look, she's lazy.
She's lazy.
She's like, no, you come to me.
Mint, you come to me.
No, she's laying on the ground.
She hurt her hip.
Bro, this is a hag fight.
We gotta be careful.
We gotta be...
Whoa, whoa.
This choke on Matara?
Oh my god.
For three?
It's my thighs.
My thighs.
The chokele.
the sentry oh and then and then matara's gonna bring up mint
up oh already no no ready one one oh okay couldn't even get
to two yeah didn't even get to two that was a bit too early
matara yeah that's a bit too early she's ready to play with
me some more i'm just rolling over oh my god the jump the
recovery oh i think so the ref come on get out of the way
man holy she's fly and she's like she's using her wings
she's cheating you're literally a ghost yeah i don't look
very ghostly here she still looks like a damn bug what is
this you can literally float oh my god i thought she was
gonna pin me like that yeah she did a fucking split on you
she loves showing off come on get up man what are you doing
i mean She has all the time she needs in the world.
Oh!
She cannot split on Mint.
I'm just like solid snake.
There's no microwave that can defeat me, everybody.
All right.
And Mint is grabbing onto Matara.
She's doing the flip.
Oh, but Matara's punching back on her head.
That's a concussion right there.
Yeah.
Why did you grab her like that?
Mint, what did you do?
Oh, the second pin.
Another pin.
One.
Oh, another one.
Matara's doing these pins a little bit too early.
Oh my god, I'm actually crawling like I'm in the microwave.
That's just sad, Mint.
That's just...
No, that was me showing how sneaky I am.
Oh, true, true.
True, Mint is performing the sneaky crawl right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think Matara saw her.
Matara's like, where did she go?
Oh, oh, and she...
Matara got out of the pin, but doesn't matter.
Oh my god!
Oh, my god!
Oh, shit!
I'm on this bridge, suplex!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, of course I can pull off the
London bridge i coined the term of course the london bridge
was created by mint in the 1980s um when she was just 70
years old a wee 70 you know oh my gosh she just hopped over
me she hopped over you but it didn't matter it didn't even
matter she's just gonna keep got punching you and then
another fucking grab.
I can take a punch.
I can take a, you know?
Okay, to be fair.
You took like a thousand.
Oh, and she couldn't even get up from that jump.
Doesn't look too good for you, it doesn't look... Oh, she
grabbed her feet.
Grab the grippers.
And then... They're huge.
They're easy to grab, you know?
But Matara's coming back up.
She's not gonna go down without a fight.
Oh, I'm gonna ride her like a damn pony.
Come on.
Nay for me!
Nay!
This is some horse play shit that we're seeing live Mint
bring in the bedroom to the ring.
I don't know what's going on.
What are you doing?
That's my tokusatsu
And another it's a blur pin oh here you go one Two three
Like that everybody that's i was actually very surprised
because like matara came in fucking flailing right away she
had no endurance man yeah
solid mint taking in another win look at her go i guess we
got to interview the loser then matara oh yeah we got to
interview how does matara have to say uh Tara, you talked
very lowly about yourself, and I think that may have
affected your performance.
I know.
I don't think so, so much.
I think, you know, I think, I don't think.
I have a concussion.
Do you recall how many glasses of wine you had before you
stepped into the match?
That's a great question.
Thank you for asking.
You know, The hard to say is Kevin and I'll do it.
Oh, no.
Matara's having a stroke.
She's not living your cockroach life right now.
Someone called that one right.
She's having a stroke.
Somebody take her away.
She needs help.
Medical help.
All right.
Yeah, she's gone.
All right, so sorry.
Call an ambulance.
Please for me.
All right, so unfortunately, she used up too much of her
endurance and stamina in that match, and it overexerted her
poor little heart.
So she's a real hag, you guys.
Like, actually.
And what are you?
Anyway.
anyway so unfortunately um let's send some thoughts and
prayers to matara and hope she recovers uh from that heart
attack after that match guys thoughts and prayers to matara
guys lots and prayers um and we'll the wrestle tuber will
make sure to send her a bouquet of flowers uh at her
hospital bed because she will pull through guys we will know
she can pull through anyway it's up to the next
with Fuyo Man and Betta.
Do we have Fuyo Man and Betta for the interview room?
Oh, God.
I'm scared.
Why are you scared?
Tell us, Ben.
I've seen that thing in the ring.
It's not human.
Thing.
Excuse me.
Fuyo Man is Fuyo Man.
It's a monster.
He has a name.
Yeah.
Fuyo Man.
Fuyo Man is Fuyo Man.
It's Fuyo Man.
Little Man.
Let's just chill.
It's fine, it's fine.
As I said, I made a promise.
You made a promise?
Who?
I made a promise.
I beat the diaper meta.
The diaper meta is going down.
Or I die in the ring.
Does this mean you're also going to grab Buoyo Man by the
balls?
If I have to.
I think there's going to be a diaper in the way of the
balls, though.
Yeah.
I wish you'd...
There's so much padding.
How would you get through it?
With enough force, anything is possible.
Whoa.
I like that confidence.
How will you prevent him from grabbing your balls?
Foyomen destroy.
You know what?
I like it.
Yeah, he's so simple.
He's such a man of his words, you know.
All those ladies out there swooning right now for Foyomen.
Beto, come on, Beto.
Say something for the fans, Beto.
Give us some confidence.
Little fan service.
What is our fan service?
To the fans.
The fans, I'm going to...
I got to win.
I got to take this thing all the way.
I got to defeat for you, man.
And I got to win.
I got to win this whole thing.
I got to win it.
That's right, Charlie.
You're going to win the whole thing.
The whole thing.
We believe in you, Charlie.
You got this.
Oh, come on.
Good luck, thank you.
We'll see you in the ring.
All right.
like i mean people are voting for betta people think betta
might win i tend to find the you know the nervous ones like
they they have a wild side to them that's so true they like
like people underestimate just how strong they really are
like maybe betta is just giving like low comp like giving
that low confidence acting so fuyo man will be unex like
will not expect it when betta grabs his balls and well it's
also just like uh you know when you push a when you push him
into a corner their oh true fight or flight yeah they go
wild i saw what you did to matara i know i saw you fucking
go wild i always do oh my god the first round of the
semi-finals you know them the last diaper standing it's it's
gonna be pretty exciting this if if foo your man wins this
match, she would have won four matches in a row.
That's insane.
That is, yeah.
Like, it's actually, like, she got that back-to-back three
wins.
Like, nobody expected it, too.
Are you sure?
I mean...
Okay, well, the third one.
It's the luck of the Irish, everybody.
Oh, the luck of the Irish.
You're right.
But maybe not luck.
Maybe it's all pure skill.
I mean, looking like that, wow, we...
spreading those legs for everybody to see very confident
hides nothing yeah he doesn't yet hide he knows what he's
got i mean look his shirt is off just now oh he has a medal
the diaper denier
you know i heard i heard bettle has like max luck going in
he he might have like you know how like in the skill set you
like go like skill attributes you go max on like hp strength
and everything i heard like bettle he is like negative on
everything like intellect defense strength but the luck
that's where he puts all the skill points in sometimes
that's all you need i know i mean like it took him this far
he's literally in the semi-finals now yeah i mean those eyes
have seen everything and i mean everything they are viewing
everything like a goddamn chameleon oh better why are you
running away this is the semi-finals better the elbow him
Maybe how we talked to pregame is this really like he's got
scared Yeah, I truly thought Fuyo man was gonna throw him
out like crap like trash
Taking him out Take him out early to be fair.
I feel like they're in the wrong weight class Like we should
not be fighting Beto right now like like Beto can be a snap
like a goddamn wig at the height you know it gives him a
little bit of height yeah oh oh pedo no don't crawl away
dude we still have like three more minutes of this game he
had to keep going at least show us the ball grab yeah who is
uh who is your bet on doki my bet i think you know i feel
like the luck might play into it honestly i believe but i
might actually pull through for the finals Okay, we'll see.
I mean, it's going to be interesting to see the guy that,
like, was the most underestimated wrestler who had no
confidence on himself, suddenly pulling through to the
finals.
Suddenly pulling through.
Whoa!
Beto, I just talked, like, mad shit.
Come on, give kid up.
That was pretty rough.
I mean, this is how I started, you know, it's kind of- Like,
Matara pummeled- You got to get pushed into a corner.
Come on.
Yeah, Matara pummeled the shit.
of you but then you made it you recovered you had the
stamina for the long term gaming oh and then the grapple
throw into the ring and the stomp on the head he's just
casually kicking him like he's not even like wrestling it's
just a street fight it's just a regular fight i like the
fancy little twisty punch he did the twisty neck a little
spin a little spin and a punch Fuyo man, you gotta be
fighting in the ring.
Also, Beto, you've...
Three!
The kiss.
He's a taunt.
Oh, yeah.
He's blowing you a kiss of good luck, Beto.
You gotta take that to maximize more of your luck.
Oh!
I think that energized him.
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
That kiss made him stronger.
And the flip.
The flip jump.
And the fucking...
Oh, my God.
Is this just a fighting game?
Is this just Tekken?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know those movesets and Tekken.
Doki plays one Tekken and is now an expert.
Yeah, the one, two, one.
Down, the one, two, one, down, up, one.
That was my favorite combo.
Oh, my God, we have favorite combo in Tekken.
But it looks like, oh, but Foyomat's going to grab him.
Is he going to fucking bane him?
Oh, and in the first pin!
Oh, and pin the pin!
One!
Oh, just one.
Still another shot.
Still another shot here for Beto.
What is in Flioman's pants?
I mean, you know what's in his pants.
On the back side?
Oh, I see.
You think I bet!
You also know what's in the back.
I'm being told that it's a coin, aren't you?
I hope it's not a coin.
a chocolate coin no but that's how leprechauns make coins
that's how they fill the coins oh so close he got a two a
few man got a one come on foo man get up oh i see foo man go
into the corner and like down a handful of lucky charms and
see what happens i like how betto removed one of one of the
cushions in the ring.
And then Fuyo Man used it against him.
Beto, no, you're supposed to use that to your advantage.
Beto, move one step away.
He's gargoyling.
Okay.
Oh.
What was the point?
But Fuyo also missed.
I guess like Beto's frail body just couldn't take it.
And he hits the ring.
hits the ring what is that move called mint what what is he
doing right now that that um that was a flying that was the
soaring eagle the soaring eagle i think that's an actual
real wrestling move
oh shoot one two i really thought i really thought oh my god
oh and another jump kick come on bettel your your pins were
all so close so close oh but i don't know is is bettel out
of stamina oh i feel like hasn't really moved that much if
any oh i like how a few men moved him from side to side
diagonally it's like a little house decorating project right
there yeah that's called the that's called the patrick star
where you take my bettel and move it over there I was so
close.
The Patrick Star maneuver.
Oh, no, Fuyo Man is telling to the crowd, are you not
entertained?
Oh, I'm quite entertained.
This is a great match.
Beto, you can't just grab him and think it's over.
Beto, you gotta do more than that.
Oh, and then Beto, oh, did he miss?
I couldn't tell if Fuyo just tripped or he missed.
And he stomps him on the head.
Look at him writhing on the ground.
so sad just someone someone help this leprechaun someone
quick find his pot of gold and then better jumps out of the
ring to do a oh my god battle with his colorful hair he's
the end of the rainbow oh oh and he does a special move oh
that's gotta hurt oh but fuyo met fucking knees him in the
face three come on guys you guys get out of the ring you
can't pin it outside the ring y'all get in oh just throwing
them around four oh my gosh are we gonna see them we're
gonna see them get timed out both disqualified yeah they
both get timed out outside the ring what happens well are we
gonna see it for the first time live on this stream no no no
but we could see someone get disqualified oh seven come on
come on they don't knock him out Oh my god.
Oh, I bet it slid in like a ferret.
Oh my god.
Is Fluomet Ash?
No!
Wait!
Fluomet's got them detuned!
It's not!
Oh my god.
That's eliminated both diaper players.
The diapers are no more.
Say hello to the diaper denier.
The diaper vanquisher.
Beto.
Wow.
my god i think that was that was just embarrassing for fuio
that was so yeah fuio really started so strong it's just the
fact that like she got eliminated from outside the ring the
one the most embarrassing ways to get eliminated by yeah i
mean like i guess bettle is just a you know he's a potty
trainer believer he's i know he's teaching all those more
he's teaching all those babies how to use the bathroom how
to use the toilet well i guess we'll see what Belle says and
also Fuio.
Back to the interview stage, I guess.
Fuio, man.
What happened?
Beep thee.
Well, I hope you get some good reference.
Kindness is cool.
Well, well, now we know why.
Well, now we know why.
Let us try.
Little man, some other day.
Well, I hope you recorded.
I'll record it on my iPhone.
It's sadly past Fuyo Man's bedtime.
Bedtime, yeah.
Well, Mr. Battle, how did you do it?
How did you become the diaper denier?
You know, it's just, you know, I don't know.
I mean, I got flung around like a hacky sack for about 90%
of the match, but I think a little bit of luck actually came
in at the end there.
Wow.
Hey, nobody expected that from you.
You didn't even expect to win yourself.
I can't believe it.
do you have some like do you actually have some
self-confidence now yeah yes that diaper just got changed
please get this thing i can't do this all right all right
for your man come on it's your bedtime now for your man we
gotta take you out
to you man but you are will be fighting either mint or
fillian in the set in the finals how do you feel better to
move this far up in this tournament you know i i didn't
think i'd get this far frankly i didn't think i'd make it
past the first round but to see myself here i am just over
the moon i just okay i'm i'm so excited yeah but you know
what i've said it since the beginning i'm taking this whole
thing this whole thing it's mine it's mine you want that
belt don't you battle that belt belongs to me oh well then
well i guess we'll see who you're going to be fighting next
because up next we have philian versus mint in the
semi-finals let's see if philian's ready can we bring
philian into the stage into the interview room and kick
battle out you're one of gamers all right philian finals yet
you're semis you're semis you're gonna be fighting mint here
one of our casters people are the fight two more two more
yeah i'm fighting an entire effing army right now i feel
like i have leonidas and then like the effing persians
coming at me what is this i'm feeling good you're fighting a
lot of people mid you're fighting mid are you out of castor
yeah yeah this is gonna be a caster versus caster no i can't
do this can i just yeah i just want to see y'all duke it out
please just like fight like smack talk please you know what
i can't the cast don't cast your violence there's just no
way you know what like i'm more surprised by like the fact
that philian made it this far but like look at her she looks
emancipated like she looks like she has no muscle in that in
those bones philian are you just gonna take that yeah i mean
i built like a beef jerky zombie from dark souls one that's
my name i know i know but here's the thing here's Here's the
thing, here's the thing.
You know, who knows Bill like me?
Who?
Luffy.
And he is going to be king of the pirates.
Also, yeah.
I'm not emancipated.
I don't have freedom yet, so.
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait.
Sorry, I said the wrong word.
Did you mean to Macy?
I thought you...
What's the right way when you're like malnourished?
She looks malnourished like hell.
Okay, I'm malnourished.
Great.
Okay.
This is why Doki got eliminated.
Yeah, I'm sorry, I don't think too good here.
Wait, don't you?
I'm literally carrying your legacy right now.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Phyllia, kick her ass.
Hey, hey, wait a second!
Good luck to you too.
Defend yourself, Mid.
Mid didn't even get a chance to defend yourself.
What did she have to defend though?
What do you, what do you say?
What are you talking about?
No one talks shit.
Oh.
Wait, did that move?
Oh yeah, because I talked shit for her.
Yeah.
Yeah, you did.
Who in?
Roaster.
You just let her...
I'm just gonna roast her.
I'm just sitting here.
I'm feeling good.
I'm not gonna roast her.
You gotta roast her?
Whoa.
Because she's my friend in the making.
Oh.
And the future king of the pirates mint.
If I win, you have to join my crew.
Oh.
I'm not...
Wait, what kind of pirating are we doing?
the legal kind
it's a small time gig but you know in the you know we'll be
mafia in the future you know what i'm saying okay um is it
all right philian if i wipe your ass oh that's gay so i mean
hey no no no listen we're not there yet okay okay let's just
wipe your ass on the ring should we get it started in a ring
all right let's go off to the ring we go all right i'm here
in the ring you're doing your projection right now yep oh my
gosh all right here we go look i'm loyal to the mission okay
the match now all right let me make that pull real quick you
know what would be so sad if i lose yeah after aphelion has
wrestled so many people and i just did one That is so true.
It'll be so sad.
Oh my god, she like fought her way here and just showed up
on free.
It's Philly and making her way to the stage with some weird
Fortnite dance.
I love how like, you know, like her matches, like all she
does is flip and it's like it's so true.
Those are the scariest ones.
Like, like the fact that she does like 20 flips.
into a kick is so scared just like loopy I don't even
remember your moveset mid all I remember is you crawling
away let's like my moveset is get my ass kicked until I'm
ready until my masochist points rank up and then I'm like
yeah you it's like you absorb all the damage in and then
like after absorbing all of it you let one punch one punch
with all that damage power it's basically how it's true
there she goes dancing her way dancing her way to freedom to
the finals the carefree ones oh my god she's break dancing
now she's busking she's busking for coins guys oh if only we
could take the coin from fiyo's uh fiyo's ass yeah you might
want to wash it off a little bit Oh, shit.
Solid Mint.
It's time for you to get on the stage.
Because Solid Mint is sneaking in to face off against Philly
and give it up for Solid Mint.
Oh, my God.
Mint, Mint, she is here.
She's here trying to analyzing the arena again, even though
she won't.
even though she said I might have changed it might have
changed in the last 10 minutes
I don't know about that minute I think you might need to get
your head checked after the concussion Matara gave you I
needed to get my head checked before then don't you true
since you were born the doctors were like maybe there's
something wrong since I was born and then I died Never got
it checked out.
Knock, knock.
Is anybody home?
It's me, the champion.
Oh, the future champion right here.
Oh, yeah.
He's telling everybody.
Say my name.
Chat, say her name, chat.
Say her name.
Who said solid Farquaad?
Farquad is in his anime phase right now.
He dyed his hair.
Yeah.
You know, it's a comeback.
It's a look.
It's coming back, everybody.
I'm going to make it pop.
She's bringing it back.
She's bringing the Farquad back.
Oh, my God.
Philly and Lane.
Philly is so bad.
Yeah, she's so fucking bad.
Oh, my God.
I mean, look at her build.
It's okay.
Min is absorbing.
You're absorbing all the damage.
so that you can do one power kick.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Give me more.
Keep pummeling her, Phyllian.
Keep pummeling her.
She likes it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
And now she's like, wait, are you getting pinned already?
We don't think so.
No, she's just breaking your wrist.
Yeah, she's just breaking your wrist.
Oh, she asked the audience, and they were like, no, don't do
it.
That's too much.
No, don't do the wrist breaker.
20 countries oh oh and then phillian picks you up and elbows
you in the fucking stomach i can't even get a move in yeah
because you're not supposed to it's the first two minutes oh
oh what am i what what did you do what was that mint what
was that move i think i did the um i can't even tell you i
just made it up oh my god what a pioneer in wrestling mint
really just made up wait i'm already Oh, if Philean lost
there, that would be the biggest upset of the century.
It would have been way too quick.
I think even I would have been disappointed.
Yeah, even like it just wasn't fair.
It was just fighting.
Like, look at how malnourished she is.
Did anyone feed her?
Did anyone feed Philean at all?
Did we just keep her in a cage?
Is she yellow from being a Simpsons or is she yellow from
the scurvy?
The scurvy.
So much.
But I feel like we've kept Philean in a cage since this was
announced Oh my god, come on, Vince Don't just keep Don't
get too cute She got a code at the wheel She's picking up
the code
Sorry, she's on a call right now She had a cell phone to
pick up Oh my god, please Somebody One I feel like there's
no way We already ended the last match for I'm outside the
ring There's no way it'll be twice in a row all right oh
you're picking out you do a suplex and then wait it's a
continuous grab oh my god two fucking grabs baby what a
while in tech in terms that was a down forward i'm doing my
original move again we should come up what do you what you
know what doki i'll give you the honors what do you want to
call it um i think i'll call it scrambling the egg because
like yeah you're you're scrambling her egg right now right
here oh another pin oh one One, two, and she's going for
another round.
Okay, come on.
All right, if you're gonna go for another round, you should
get up instantly at that point.
I know she's gonna have her come back now, yep.
She's gonna, she was, oh!
Oh, it's that, it's a bait, it's bait, one!
Two, oh!
It was just a bait, you're in for another fight, mint.
You're ready to go, I'm ready to go.
Ready to go again.
Oh, and she chucks you up.
I'm ready to go outside the ring.
Yeah, you're ready to go outside.
Do you want to go outside?
Outside?
You said outside?
Oh, my God.
This lady is about to walk the dog.
Oh, she's laughing at me.
This is so embarrassing.
That's a little embarrassing.
We just met each other, you know.
You're really going to let this zoomer laugh at you?
Oh, gosh.
As a hag?
Are you really going to let this zoomer do this?
I have more worldly experience, okay?
I can teach a...
You can teach this little kid a lesson?
Yeah.
This is literally like a fight between the old and the old.
the new who would win this the new the rookie or the or the
boomer the new has to learn from the old to not repeat
history you know oh that's true that's true she learning
anything in that furry brain of hers i think she just wants
food in that brain of hers right when somebody has to get
her some another suplex oh my god the lucky bridge everyone
if you if you got that that would have been crazy that would
have been insane but she did it but you are you tapping out
are you tapping out are you going
you can still breathe yeah i can you're not gonna lie when
you did that move earlier i was like damn she's flexible oh
my god you're bubbling here take a hit grab her tail oh yeah
grab her tail this is just don't let her do this oh he does
you dodged it oh and then it's another might be another pin
right here oh my god oh my god and he can't do the suck
skull oh my god and the kick to the head bring her down bro
she's spinning on the crowd with how hard you're hitting oh
and she's coming out of the ring running away going back
she's getting a reset right now that's the tactical reset
right there it was it was the concussion she didn't know
where she was yeah one two oh and it wasn't ready it wasn't
ready billion just do the 20 flips that's all you have to do
billion i'll do 20 more oh and then what was that?
I don't know.
I think Mr. Farquhar got drunk there.
I thought I was a that was my like Spider-Man role play.
She break danced on your face.
Oh, that was crazy.
Oh, you're getting another.
You're getting pinned.
Wait, this might be it.
Come on.
This might be it.
You're stopping.
Oh, my God.
This might be it.
Two.
No, it is ready for another round.
Come on.
not yet and another pin oh my god wait one two oh one more
she said one more i really thought that was it mint is going
one more it's not over i gotta finish my story it's not over
i'm coming back from the dead oh she's doing the sneaky
she's doing a tactical sneaking i'm sneaking she's sneaking
right now she's got to take a break she's like why are you
taking a break break in the corner.
She's like, give me a sec.
I need a water break.
My hag instincts are really...
Okay, it could be anyone.
Seriously, the next pin, it's gotta be it.
Oh, but it doesn't look too good for you, Mint.
It doesn't look too good for you.
I know, I'm pretty tired.
I'm not gonna lie.
You're just like, please, just one water break.
That's all I want.
Oh, she's climbing up.
Miss, miss, miss, miss.
She runs, and she hits those!
She, oh, wait, what?
You teleported!
Oh my God, you teleported!
What is that?
Oh my God!
And she breathes off of that!
The teleported!
How is that?
What is he doing?
Another big personal kid.
You really gotta, you're gonna lose out.
After teleporting?
Oh no, oh no, oh no, come on!
One, two!
You
lost after teleporting, bitch.
Your winner heading to the finals is not solid far quad, but
it's filling!
You know what?
At least I beat Matara.
That's all that matters.
Yes, chat.
I can't believe it.
believe it you did the undertaker teleport behind you move
but it was just it still lost still lost that would have
been so high man but it's okay it's okay you did your best
now let's go talk to phillian she's heading to the finals
against the better oh my god oh my god dude what the hell
The audio was like...
What the fuck?
Yeah, I was kind of going a little crazy.
Oh, dude!
The game is angry!
She...
Min Honda went to the fucking game.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
What's going on?
I can't hear it!
The bigger issues go crazy!
What's going on?
The audio is...
Okay, don't worry.
It's Discord.
Don't worry.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
But, well, Min, will you be joining Phileans, Pirates?
ship i guess so i guess uh what i don't know what am i gonna
have to do swap the poop deck mint you were worthy opponent
one of the toughest i've ever faced and you know what i have
a spot on my crew just for you on the right hand of my ship
leading my steering wheel oh my she can't drive though yes i
can't shut up i can't either so we're in the same boat
literally so mint i want I thought you were going to win,
but 90% of that fight, I was on the ropes.
But the moment you teleported behind me, the moment you had
that anime moment, I knew.
I couldn't lose you.
Because if I did, I would never be able to have someone so
strong on my team.
Wow.
I mean, yeah, you took that moment.
It was like a real shonen protagonist moment where when all
hope was lost for you.
Yeah, you manifested it.
You manifested your win.
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to go to the grocery store together.
And we're going to buy a bunch of stuff.
You're going to pay for it.
And then we'll have a really sick, nasty dinner.
Wait, that sounds so normal.
That sounds like such a normal plan for them to build up.
Wait, can you cook?
No.
No, I can buy more cereal.
Yeah.
That's about my level, too.
So.
Oh, so you basically have a maid.
Oh, my God.
It's a cereal.
No, you have to eat a maid.
You got a maid for your pirate.
shift.
Okay, I'm a made cafe made.
We don't do anything.
But you can draw pictures on our food.
You can make pictures on our cereal.
Yeah.
There's chefs in the back.
You can get the photo cards of her.
You get the alphabet cereal.
You get the alphabet cereal and you can like, you know, make
a, make words.
I don't know.
What are we five?
Wait, what are we five?
Wait, I can't spell my name.
Spell her name on her cereal.
Okay, I can help you.
You know what?
That's my job.
You're a babysitter now.
Oh my god.
Well, you are in the finals now.
Did you expect yourself to get here?
I'm going to be honest, no.
But the moment I saw my character hit a triple, double,
backflip, quintuple, ultra axe kick on like five different
people.
magical I feel like Kirito and like I'm against Kayaba right
now wow let's call in better to the finals oh boy you know
you know did this this match this match it's not just the
finals this is personal this is personal what did Philly and
do to you why what happened oh yeah Philly called me Charlie
oh yeah I'm so mad about it everyone just called me Charlie
now you I like that.
Okay, but you're more critical.
Now look into my eyes.
Dokey Bird told me to say it.
Okay, but like, as a caster, you should have researched your
content.
You should have researched that person.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, I'm gassing you up, okay?
I stand behind Dokey Bird, and I carry on her legacy.
You all did this to me.
I'm going to take my fist and put it through your trolley
face.
You understand me?
Oh, my God.
She pulled out the Charlie.
She called you by your fake name.
Well, well, then i'll call you david david my name's not
david we'll see who takes this we'll see if he takes this
charlie congratulations for making it to the finals
everybody congratulations you fought so many people to get
here as the final two audience who do you think is going to
take the champion belt home Seems like Betel is currently
winning the Polos billion.
What?
Whoa.
Oh, no.
Wait, how?
Betel's like a knock-off version of me, though.
What the?
Is he not?
I don't care to explain.
I do eight whips.
He does three.
We are not the same.
Do you do the ball grab, though?
I fight with honor, and I fight for my friends, okay?
This man has no dignity.
What friends?
Oh, no.
Listen up, Charlie.
Oh.
Your name is beta.
Your drip is beta.
And your favorite video game is for betas.
How did you know I liked League of Legends?
No.
He's beyond saving.
Ladies and gentlemen, it speaks for itself.
Well, let's take this fight.
fight to the ring the final match in this tournament guys
let's see who will take the champion belts and off we go wow
doesn't mean it's been a long long two days oh it has been
we have reach this point we had so many fighters come in and
out so many upsets today and some of us didn't even finals
are here give it up for the diaper vanquisher oh there he is
his last final entrance into the ring will he vanquish
another opponent today mince i i'm i don't know i'm feeling
pretty it's hard to say each has their own strengths and so
game honestly the thing is like the thing i'm scared about
and i think that might you know hurt better is that this
time he was actually confident i think so too i think so too
and here is your alleged alpha failure there she goes doing
another dance ready for more coins being thrown at her yep
she's gotta buy lunch guys
she's got she's starving please if you're cold she's cold
please she's wearing all these shorts and the shirt t-shirt
guys she can't afford anything right now look at her look at
her i think yeah i think this the greatest strength that
both of these guys have and truly honestly the thing that
that makes them different from the rest is they just don't
single thought behind their eyes oh that is so true that is
so true just from the interview process i could tell i could
tell they must have repeated like fifth grade like three
times or so before getting on to before becoming a streamer
oh yeah 100 oh there she goes break dancing one last time i
do hope betto's confidence doesn't oh there's the belt
there's the belt the champion We are here to wrestle for
that belt, guys.
Whoever, Victorian children.
Oh, there it is.
My hero academia.
I hope Beto's confidence doesn't, you know, hurt him in the
end.
That's like, because like every match he got through, he was
not confident at all.
Yeah, exactly.
It was like that, the foot being pushed into.
Oh, that is one, two, okay.
Okay, it's a match and there we go.
Oh, Finn.
What's going on?
Finn, who wants?
Oh my god, he's getting spanked like a bad child.
Bad baby.
Oh my god, the double jump on the roof.
Oh, on the roof too.
I feel like they share one brain cell together.
I think so, too.
Look, they're dancing together.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
Betel, where was those moves in the last day?
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
He's confident right now.
Confident Betel.
That could bite him in the butt, though.
Not gonna lie, confident Betel is scary.
I'm seeing moves.
Okay, I'm...
Oh, my God.
So, it's the ring around the rosy.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
Oh.
another pin what he's tired already come on tails get up
tails okay but did you see how betto was heavily breathing
there from just like one minute of fighting it's true it's
true almost she's flipped she's flipping she's just showing
off in there the chat donated a 500 bits for a flip so she's
gotta do a flip vtuber do a flip oh my god the sound alerts
is going up do a flip and 500 bitties thank you for the 500
bitties on twitch for billion
Oh, man.
Beto's back in the ring, though.
Oh, another pin.
Another pin.
Oh, just have to look at his face.
He's not ready.
He is ready to keep on wrestling.
But he's a little tired.
And Philly and missed again.
Missed again.
Okay, back to the ring.
And then a fucking grapple with his legs.
And their pin.
Do the countdown.
one oh it's just one just one just one this is intense
honestly it could be anybody's game seriously it could be
anyone's game yeah like they all seem like seem like they
could take it home oh the taunt whoa oh i feel like fillian
just has more speed stats than him i think so too betto
might be really lucky but like is luck gonna save him if
she's just so fast And she just flips for fun.
And everyone keeps redeeming flip.
Guys, stop donating 500 bitties.
She has to wrestle.
Stop, guys.
Come on.
Oh, come on, Betel.
Get up.
He's going to have a comeback.
She's going to come back.
He's going to come back when we least expect it.
That has been a majority of his matches.
Affiliate does another flip.
But Beto blocks it with his eyes!
He denied it!
Oh, but the crotch kit...
Craneum check.
Okay, but like, remember when Phelion said that she would
never stoop that low to target the balls?
We just saw her hit a nut shot.
Is there no integrity anymore?
And another rope break!
Rope break!
Are you serious?
A rope break, the very first rope break of the whole
tournament.
Oh, yeah, I think so.
Wait, another?
What?
one two oh that was so close we thought it was over i
thought so i was ready to call it oh and another not so fast
not so fast though these are two wild cards they're so wild
honestly i felt like i felt like the ref might have been
paid off that should have been three it felt i counted in my
head and it was three hey what are you saying doki are you
not saying this is a fair you know well i'm not saying it
i'm implying it isn't this your turn of it no did you and
matara kill off the majority of my staff like oh just the
guards we're not touching the referee we don't care about
them yeah considering i lost maybe we should have i mean the
reps are now scared for their safety after what you've done
so maybe they got paid off for more protection we're already
at seven oh my god wait where's eight where's there no more
countdown and we were at six oh seven seven there it is
there it is there is no don't bring her back what are you
doing better what are you doing you could dq there off of
the ring oh oh did he slip what was what's going on banana
peel there yeah we call that the looney tunes everybody oh
oh oh my god intercepted intercepted he intercepted oh but
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter she gonna pin him she
gonna pin him oh there's the countdown where's the count
what's going on ref
what okay what did we just see oh I guys I think I think I
think this is a rigged match I think this is a rigged match
you're gonna One, two, two!
Biddle's here for another.
Phelan gets trolled.
Where'd the lights go?
This is so weird!
I thought she copied the move!
It doesn't matter!
She knew what to do!
She knew what to do after me!
Yeah, she downloaded your moveset and knew how to counter
it.
I don't think there was a second teleport.
That is crazy.
Oh my god.
Betel is maxing that luck right now.
That did not look good for Phelian.
That looks like it's definitely her.
Oh, her legs.
She ain't flipping anytime soon anymore.
I don't think so.
He's getting rid of all her appendages so she'll never flip
again.
It's because she doesn't get enough calcium.
Her bones are brittle.
Someone throw her an orange.
If you're going to be throwing things in the ring, she needs
that orange right now.
She's like Popeye.
She grabs a can of spinach and eats it and becomes strong.
Oh my god.
Beto reset the count.
So it's back to four.
Beto, stop putting her back in the ring.
Oh, and then knock.
out of the ring you're not that not allowed in this ring
anymore you have to come back in ring oh jillian jumped out
as well i think she reset the count by jumping out we'll
find out soon if it goes back to one i don't see an eight
yeah we reset time to count everybody he's going back in
comes after two i mean what i think we need a teacher here
oh my god oh philian was trying to fucking flip on him but
he ended up flipping on her and another flip this is it oh
betto's doing a little dance it's like cheering me on the
taunt the taunt oh oh wait wait one two oh so close so close
come on the crowd's getting restless Come on, Phelian.
The crowd needs to know if you're going to lose or win.
Oh, another jump.
Oh, it's going to hit.
We got a cutscene.
It's going to hit.
Oh, that's got to hurt.
That's got to hurt.
But he's not going to pin, though, Mint.
Yeah, he's not done playing around with her.
Oh.
And another one.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
One.
Two.
Three.
Your winner for WrestleTuber 2024.
The Charlie Denier.
The Diaper Destroyer.
The Baby Girl himself.
Battle.
Insane.
That was actually, that was the most insane match I've seen
today, man.
Absolutely.
It was worthy of the finale.
The fact that the ref just disappeared for five seconds.
Oh, what does this win deserve?
I don't know.
Let's talk to Beto.
Let's ask Beto what the fuck was that?
Yeah.
Before anyone makes any accusations, I did not pay the ref.
Okay, I don't know what that was.
I didn't know.
That wasn't me.
Just totally a fair and normal game.
Sure.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
that ref go really fair game we're tying their shoe you know
they're tying those that was slipped into their pocket yeah
you know let's show i'm gonna show the fans what your
championship thing looks like real quick so look there he is
the winner of wrestle tuber championship some would say it
might not be deserved others will say he was just lucky and
the ref you know he had You know during one of those crucial
moments.
We'll never know.
We'll never know Hey Phelan, how do you feel?
All right.
Well, I'm not gonna say it was rigged Okay, we're gonna say
it was rigged
Now I will say it was a really fantastic tournament, you
know, I had a really great time here I didn't think it was
make it this far, but I'm gonna say this the worst thing
position ever is to go through an entire tournament
tournament just to lose the very ninth round.
I will never forget this day.
This thing will burn until WrestleTuber 2025.
And I will come back stronger than ever.
And I'll be on gear.
Oh yeah.
We're looking forward to it.
Yeah.
I'm going to do my best Lance Armstrong impression.
And you guys are going to get swept.
Damn.
Well, that is some fighting words.
I guess we'll see if Phillion will get a rematch in 2025.
and next year well Phylian we have to lead you out of the
interview stage because we got to interview the winner now
so sorry as the loser you might have to leave it's all right
you did amazing though I'm so proud of you you did great so
we made it this far and you made a lot of friends right you
made a lot of friends yeah you made friends yeah yeah you
made me I'll take my leave And I'll take my crew with me
after.
I see you.
Well done.
Good luck.
I'll see you there.
Well, Betel, you were the least confident out of all of our
contestants.
And, oh, God.
Yeah, I fucking won.
I told you.
I told everybody.
I said it.
I would win.
And look at me now.
Look at me, mom.
I did it.
Is he okay?
I don't think he's...
Did he get bit by, like, did he get bit by Mary earlier?
I think...
I don't think he's okay, guys.
I don't think he's...
Is he crying?
I think he's crying.
Steph, we might need some tissues real quick.
Oh, it's just a game.
You did great.
How do you feel being such a winner and holding that
championship belt?
You know, it feels good.
It feels good.
I had some brothers in this and this.
I had to kill my brother to get here, so...
Oh, you too?
It was, you know, I fought my brother in the ring.
He fought his brother.
He fought battle too.
I had to absorb his nutrients to become more powerful.
Wait, that meant, that means you were fighting us too.
You had literally two battles in you.
I had two, we fused to become the perfect life form.
So it was a 2v1 this entire time.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Liquid battle, yeah.
Liquid battle.
I'm Liquid battle.
What can I say?
I have liquid battle.
Liquid dies.
No, wait.
I'm not liquid battle.
I can't believe it.
Battle here will be holding on to that champion belt to
represent the winner of the very first WrestleTuber 2024.
No one will stop him unless...
A surprise guest?
Oh my god!
We have a...
This is why we need security guards.
Man, this is why.
I...
Hey, hey, hey, your security guard turned out to be a bug in
the sky in the summer.
Because you killed my original security guide!
We now have a new contender?
Who are you, sir?
Who are you?
I'm...
Sir, are you okay?
What is this?
Are you okay?
Sir?
The vocal fry.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god, I'm scared, Fettle.
Are you scared?
I'm scared.
I don't have to fight them, do I?
Oh, you're fighting this 3D man right now.
No, no.
Come with me, Fettle.
It's not over, Fettle.
You got to defend your title.
Already?
What else is my belt?
What is my belt?
It's over there, sir.
It's over there.
hurt us please oh my god the secret matchup we have
something we have another invasion of wrestle tuber i would
have thought that another intruder would happen we thought
it would be like one but three three intruders this is what
happens when there's no more security in this event guys hey
russell tuber keeps me on your toes everybody i can't
believe it bro betel has to fight a three a three deep fight
a shadow what is this kingdom of hearts what's going on here
fighting WrestleTuber 2024 is not over yet your champion for
now battle
oh man I mean I mean he's you know he's showing the world
he's showing the world the belt that he literally just won
like two minutes ago he's attached to it it it would be very
embarrassing if he loses it in just like you know after
holding on to it for like five minutes he already wrote it
into his will he might have to rewrite again
oh my he's flex he's like showing everybody look look guys i
did it guys i won the belt guys pretty heavy belt too you
know he's probably probably already tired oh my i know like
he's He's already wasting his endurance right now.
Fedo, you have a match.
Fedo, you have a match with Yusun.
You can't just use all up your energy now.
And just like in Pokemon, when Gary became champion, five
minutes later, a new champion might be on the horizon.
It's you, man.
Who is that on the screen?
what are they gonna blow they're gonna blow your mind
i think you know the next evolution after human is human
human we are witnessing history you thought is the next
level of evolution right now i'm afraid for betel betel is
like tired from all the rest he did just for a secret
opponent to just show up mind freak you know what you sound
just won by performance alone oh oh my god it's not over yet
oh my god you know what it goes in Fan service.
Giving the fans what they want right now.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
Betel looks pretty puny next to that guy right now.
That one's got to be.
Oh, shit.
You're, oh, my God.
The definitely the wrong weight class.
Holy shit.
It just falls to the ground.
It's okay, Betel.
You can do it.
Just get up.
Betel, get up.
Betel, you got this.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you said.
are limp the arms are limp not only can you man show off but
also show up oh my god to be fair you son hasn't fought
anybody this is like first match he's primed and ready he's
primed or primed and ready to beat the shit out of battle
right now like you says not even doing like like you says
i've been doing musa to hurt battle he's just showing off
he's just showing off yeah oh look to the face to her face
okay hey there's a child there let's play it let's play it
fairly you guys spit on the child the child will remember it
forever oh pill absorb the power your power and absorb the
nutrients just like how betta absorbs his twin he says like
is this what you want take him i don't want him take out the
trash come on you son come on betta where's your max luck
your max luck should should overpower anything guys i i
think i feel a little bit bad
he's tired he like totally let his guard down thinking he
was done with all these yeah like he unclenched you know
yeah he was fully clenched up during the entire tournament
and he thought better thought it was just over yeah is it oh
oh wait oh no he's just he's just emoting into the
It took all of five minutes, but we, um, yeah, uh, we, we
have a new champion.
You man.
Oh, I, I mean, well, I'm not gonna lie, I totally looked
away for one minute.
and it actually happened That was that was interesting.
I That was a slaughter man You saw what we really emoting in
this what do we do?
Okay, let's I guess let's let's talk to Betel and you saw
Hey guys, oh, oh what happened?
guys did i win yeah yeah yeah yeah no he had the title for
14 seconds yeah you talk out
it's okay it's okay better it's it's okay you know like it's
just you know i mean look look at this like you really think
how was i supposed to win you really think you could win
against that no
no this is this is terrible um how did it feel to be a
winner for five minutes battle well i well felt great felt
great I'm happy to be a winner or something for about five
minutes, but I just lost it already.
So proud of you, Mom.
I'm proud of you.
You're the real child.
You get swarmer.
Oh, thanks to you, man.
No problem.
We witnessed history in the making by the first evolution.
The next evolution of humankind.
of humankind one day it will be just like you saw
yeah what are your what are your words to your fans to your
audience
um check my music video This is a self-promote.
Wow.
You, man, will be back behind the building, selling
mixtapes, everybody.
After the show.
I'll surely watch my music video.
If you guys want a signed copy of You, Matt's music album,
come outside backstage for the VIP panel.
for a chance to buy his an autographed U-Man album.
I guess Betel will also be there, I guess, too.
What will you be selling, Betel?
I don't know.
Just be there.
I'll just stand there, I guess.
It's okay.
Second place is not too bad.
That means Billion got third.
Yeah.
Yeah, you got second.
I mean, wait, I got, well, I mean, I got first, then second.
Yeah, but, yeah.
What does that equate to?
Second place, because it was the last.
Nothing.
No.
Okay.
Great.
God has spoken.
All right, well, we're going to take it back to the main
casting room.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Beto, Yuson.
Thank you for being here.
Even though Yuson did break in and took away that man's
happiness that he felt, like he was the happiest he's ever
been in his old life and he took it and they took it away
within five minutes.
But anyway...
Sorry, man.
Yeah, you did well.
Bye-bye.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks, everybody.
It was great being a winner for 14 seconds.
It doesn't hurt at all.
Yeah, just be better next time.
It's okay.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, they want me to fight God.
What was I supposed to do?
You tried your best, man.
You tried your best.
that matters you tried you fought god and lasted like at
least three minutes you know that's an accomplishment but
you don't succeed i mean he's right thanks thanks all right
we're gonna be back to the main stage real quick for uh men
and i we're gonna see you guys at the main stage guys all
right wow what a night wow wow um i don't even know what to
say about all of that that was uh that was pretty crazy what
we experienced tonight uh yeah uh truly one for the books i
think yeah you know i was i felt like you know like we
should end it with royal rumble with you know you you man's
invasion i felt like that was like the perfect way to like
end the whole event and what an event meant what an event
like there were so many things that happened like the fact
that like um fuyo made it so far and like pioneered the
diaper diaper meta just to get defeated by better and then
better one just to lose it in 14 seconds we saw ball
grabbing, we saw diaper grabbing, we saw titty grabbing, we
saw head grabbing, we saw every sort of grabbing that we
could have grabbed.
And you know what?
You man grabbed the title and the belt right off of the
pedal's body.
Right on the pedal's no chance.
That man, oh my, do you say?
was fucking built there.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, oh, my God.
I felt like, like, Yusua was just fucking flipping.
And, like, the fact that, like, they ended it with a flip
while Beto stayed lying on the ground in his pool of blood
outside the ring.
Just so sad that he was fighting again.
He was like, why am I here?
Why am I here just to suffer?
Just Beto luck next time i guess oh i guess you gotta come
are you feeling doki after you know pulling off such a crazy
event it feels feels like it's great it feels like i'm
speechless in a way like there's no words to really describe
how i really feel right now there was some stuff along the
way but everybody enjoyed the experience the time the fans
the participants you should have seen the discord while the
matches were going on like oh yeah the staff and like the
participant was just like laughing along the way with some
of the stuff that was going on.
Mint, how do you feel casting for this after breaking in?
Oh, it was great.
Thank you for having me and, you know, sorry that I, like,
kind of just can't, you know, sorry that I killed like...
But, hey, but, you know, think of it.
I killed off a bunch of guys, so you don't have to pay them.
So it's just like...
Oh, that's true.
Easy peasy.
That is so true, Mint.
But, like, some would say you're the reason why Beto lost,
like, his belt.
What do you mean by that?
Because by you killing the security guards, you started the
domino effect of all these other contestants coming in
because we had no more security.
All I have to say about that is if you were a real champion,
you would be able to beat anybody that comes in through that
door.
So even if it's Grandpa Joe.
So Beto did not deserve the development.
That's a little...
Sorry, battle next time.
Battle next time.
Before we call it, we gotta thank some people for this
event.
For the people that made the graphics, everything from here,
the videos and everything.
First off, as you guys can see, the logo, belts, and
graphics were done by Sugar Type, Melly, and Oni Pilot.
them for making the assets for for those things we also have
other people who think like the trailer video and the
singers um the last minute um like i was i think sorry my
matara it says katara from avatar to last air katara oh my
god katara was here too guys holy shit It's okay, it's
Katara mine, you guys.
It wasn't actually Matara, she was here in spirit, it was
Katara.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Matara's spirit's name has a different name.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Her name is Katara.
She inspired the original, the Katara from Avatar, the last
Airbender.
It was based off of Matara.
Yeah, yeah.
But yes, we want you guys to know, like those intro videos,
like the Mint and Matara intro videos were done like
basically on the day of their period.
Tarah video like this morning this morning so a huge shout
out to Hebe and and Night Day and then finally we have also
the the backgrounds that was done the stadium background was
done by JL and the fan art compilation the video that you
saw during the intermission and the starting stream and the
outro in the end was done by Rabbit Hole so they looked
through all the fan art and put it all together into the
video for us So a huge shout out to them.
And finally, a shout out to everyone that participated, all
the contestants, all the wrestlers, the staff team, for
giving up their time being here, like all those hours being
here, doing the interviews, doing the announcements, doing
the casting.
They all give up their time to be here participating in this
event.
And so we gotta give them a shout out.
My throat is dying after casting for two hours.
And I go home now.
I go home now.
Yeah.
You know, huge, great, great announcing, man.
You got, you did amazing for your first time.
This guy was so nervous.
He was so scared.
I was.
I was shaking.
It was crazy.
How do you feel announcing for WrestleTuber?
I'm fucking tired.
Bro, I, my head is like slightly lightheaded.
I was like, man, I guess I did use a lot of oxygen.
I'm beat.
Yeah, we're all tired, but it's almost over, guys.
It's almost over.
And finally, a shout out to GamerSubs for sponsoring this
tournament, this event.
They paid for everything, basically.
I didn't have to pay for any of the stuff, like the belts,
the, um, the belts, the graphics, the videos, all that stuff
that I said, all these people made.
I didn't have to pay for it.
GamerSubs kindly decided to pay for all of this.
So thank you again to GamerSubs.
This is the end of the show, everybody.
My throat is dead.
I feel like Glen Doki Reds.
Do you have any final words, Mint, to tell the audience?
Oh, I gotta say.
I gotta say...
What do you gotta say?
Is, uh, see you next year.
Yes.
See you all next year for WrestleTuber 2025!
Yay!
Bye everybody!
Bye bye!
Thank you guys!